petit à petit voir lire vos messages
dans le chat aussi vous voulez ça
arrivait dans le chatt bienvenue chez
envergure retour vers le futur retour
sur la draft 2010 est dé retour avec les
les chroniqueurs de l'époque
qui n'ont pas changé physiquement
qui seront toujours que les mêmes nous
avons nous avons dans l'ordre alors
d'abord moi je me rappelle plus comment
cet excès envergure mais je sais
envergure mais je sais que lui il était
là dès le début il a fait des directs
depuis des bars il a les l'homme des
hautes tech des connexion 2g dans la
campagne française ont même il est un
peu notre jean castex notre homme des
nantais manu c'est manu sava manu trop
d' insulte comme ça t'es pas gentil
dans le dans le bon sens du jean castex
c'est à dire le salut à tous par contre
en temps un peu en décalé je ne sais pas
d'où ça vient a du brésil
c'est le temps que ça traverse
l'atlantique
j'espère que ça va aller nous avons
également vous l'avez entendu ben a aimé
retrouver sa voix de stentor at il dit
il a beaucoup de miles
parce qu'ils voyagent beaucoup j'ai
passé incite à accumuler sa sur une
carte romain leroy qui on le rappelle
assistant la sig strasbourg
non non je viens d'où là où ces derniers
vous alors dernier voyage c'était en
grèce il ya la semaine dernière le pas
au kitsch dans la dans la ville
portuaire de de salonique hook et
salonique en fonction des orientations
historique et le prochain voyage c'est
levallois samedi et vit nu 60 prochain
donc tu as bien manger en grèce en
lituanie s'annonce plus compliqué nos
relais messieurs baffe j'ai l'habitude
lituanie ccg un pays où je vais souvent
mais la grèce oui c'était plutôt plutôt
plutôt normalement
très bien et bien nous avons également
en gros plan puisqu'il nous fait le
plaisir de de ce film est de près
toujours le
linate de seul défaut que les équipes
qu'il soutient finalement les new york
knicks et manchester united
je veux bien évidemment parler quoi du
québec libre la voix libre du québec
benoît lelièvre quand on va être lui
même
le brésil pas bien va bien le ciel est
bleu ouais ce qui peut encore non hier
si ce n est pas la chance j'avais versé
aux versions dans le congélo oui c'est
ça c'est ça non on n'a pas les mêmes les
mêmes fahrenheit vous comptez en faire
un à québec non non ah bon on a des
animaux
dans mieux graver 2017 messieurs je vais
commencer avec une introduction pourquoi
ben
c'est une catastrophe cette draft ans
quand je joue je me suis fait le tableau
plusieurs fois je me suis dit c'est une
catastrophe
oui clairement non c j'ai essayé de
calculer mon nombre de victoires
quelques voix
soit
j'ai peut-être cinq ou six joueurs parce
qu'il ya la raison ici il faut que je
descends
je crois comprenez c'est dur
ici c'était plus facile de prévoir les
échecs que les réussi
parce que alors donc on va on va quand
même revenir petit à petit sur le
classement mais je rappelle rapidement
juste le top 5 markel felt lonzo ball
jason tatum joe jackson dit aaron fox
sur un top 5 quatre ans après avoir un
joueur qui a montré très peu de choses
le top pick le deuxième pic qui a un
très bon joueur mais qui n'est pas du
tout ce qu'on pouvait attendre d'un
deuxième pic et joe jackson qui est
quasiment sûr hilali taf est même
quasiment
c'est pas terrible c'est pas terrible
après entre 5 et 10 ça s'améliore pas
c'est
pas compliqué nathanaël zag franck tilly
qui n'a dé nice miss junior collins tout
ça c'est du cdu c'est pas de la réussite
franche
franche et
donc donc je commence avec romain romain
j'aimerais que tu me dises
kita à l'époque tu es tu es t au sur
mark allen
j'y réponds que gt gt g/t au / mark
allen je l'avait défendu bec et ongles
lors de ses premiers élèves qu'on avait
fait à l'époque avec les camarades de
[Musique]
2 ha oui tu te rappelles avec nos amis
de rage oublie posters de
tarnac arden quin y avait kevin y avait
un petit peu tout le monde moi j'avais
joué le truc en cours de roots comme avg
avec un invité un petit peu un petit peu
en dernière minute donc je davantage
c'est que ça permet d'éviter de da sur
une quelconque erreur mais
non il ya eu des jets assez haut sur
mark allen m'ont déjà parce que je
l'avais je l'avais je l'avais joué en
équipe de france u20 j'ai eu la chance
de le voir nous découper très proprement
sur les sur les matchs de poules heures
en finlande sur la suivre la rencontre
qu on avait joué contre au premier tour
de l'euro et
globalement je suis assez content de son
parcours 1 sur ce qu'il a fait jusque là
mais des erreurs j'en ai pas mal
effectivement donc
choisir une à la plus évidente pour moi
cfls
après
pourquoi ils nombreux à se planquer oui
la question étant qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché avec
bas il ya toujours ce côté un peu
impossible à prévoir qui est lié au
nombre incroyable de blessure qu'il
enchaînait quand même pas ce que c'est
c'est quelque chose qui lui un petit peu
un petit peu coupé le coupé l'élan pompe
à dire les jambes sans faire de mauvais
de mauvais esprit après derrière
son garçon son adaptation la ligue
notamment sur le problème principal qui
était le sien qui est qu'elle tire
c'était quelque chose je pense que
jusqu'à la cathédrale victoire est là
j'ai regardé un petit peu il encore des
cabines matches joués cette année ça
risque d'être encore un petit peu un
petit peu en calvaire sur globalement
globalement en carrière il a j'ai pas le
souvenir qu'il est fait si la saison
2009 2020 qui était complète dans le
contexte qu'on connaît malgré tout le
reste après derrière on s'est laissé
c'est difficile quoi
on est ronde et pas loin on n'est pas
loin du n'est pas loin du bust à
proprement parler le concernant est ce
que je comprend 1 pour 1 pour un premier
choix c'est
pour l'instant seychelles --dont
contraire c'est plutôt faibles souvent
pour évaluer un peu la réussite on
regarde tout simplement la valeur du
deuxième contrat du joueur et la basse
et 50 millions sur trois ans donc c'est
pas on est très très loin du max
du max extension ou qui a été signée par
quatre roues qui si mon compte est bon
de cette cuvée la jason statham diane
fox
donovan mitchell et bam adebayo
l'huile est plutôt cher de l'eure même
bassin complètement
horaire un peu trop important toi tu toi
tu tues tu dis
pas prévisible est ce que enfin on sait
qu'il ya une batterie de tests médicaux
quand tu draft un joueur généralement tu
sais s'il est fragile ou pas s'il est si
la des fragilités à certains endroits à
kehl à quel point ces évaluations elles
sont fiables et à quel point on peut se
tromper
c'est ceux là on rentre je ne sais pas
parce qu'on n'a pas accès aux dossiers
médicaux donc c'est compliqué mais
globalement 17 matches la première année
19 la deuxième
tu tu rentres après dans un cycle tu as
des joueurs comme ça qu'ils ont des
prédispositions qui ce qu'ils baissent
qui blesse et qui quand sort john est
donc certains y arrivent à travaux de
quelques années est-ce que c'était pas
trop tôt c'est toujours pareil quand
t'as pas qu'on n'a pas toutes les infos
tu peut extrapoler et finalement renoncé
roman c'est l'histoire c'est totalement
improbable après bon c'est
l'évolution l'évolution technique du
joueur a n'a pas été là pas été
transcendante mais après tout est lié je
veux dire tu t'es tout le temps blessé
tu peux pas vraiment évolué tu ne joues
pas tu as pas de temps de jeu
psychologiquement n'est pas forcément au
mieux non plus mais je pense qu'ensuite
tout s'imbrique est coté dans un schéma
blessures non progression et eu mes
sandales équation très attendu qui était
logiquement placé sur toi parce que tu
es forces pique
un peu logique que par que ce soit que
ce soit compliqué ombre avons c'est
encore un c'est un joueur qui a un grain
de quatre ans donc et pas encore qui
peut encore acheter aux orties mais
ce ne sera pas facile ouais ben il ya eu
pendant longtemps cette attend d'abord
manu toi t t au sur fall tsupa gens qui
croyaient université de washington à
l'époque on le rappelle il fait une
année
exceptionnelle
moi j'y croyais fortement mais plus la
faute sur lui je la mets sur les six
heures en fait à 100%
qu'ils ont dès qu'il est arrivé dans la
ligne plus changé son shoot et à partir
du moment où ils ont voulu changer son
shoot mais il s'est blessé à l'épaule
est jamais revenu
donc moi je la la faute n'est pas ce
qu'on l'a vue soit les six heures ça que
des sur les sur orlando il ya eu quand
même pas mal de bons flashs où il était
on retrouvait à un peu le joueur qu'il
était à washington à washington il était
juste incroyable ça va tout faire pour
la pauvre trois points à mi distance et
véritable créateur même dans une équipe
qui était pas forcément la meilleure du
monde mais aujourd'hui monde à l'époque
qu est ce qui nous faisait faire
beaucoup de zones et on attaque c'était
pas dingue mais
moi les flèches du magic j'ai envie de
toujours y croire et je met
principalement où est la faute sur les
six ans sur le star des sixers qu'a
voulu faire chier pas quoi avec son
shoot qui était très bien il ya tout
d'un coup ils ont dit non à le changer
en fait et 20 ans on salut les amis du
chat il ya julien et blu des villes qui
sont arrivés et il ya louis qui est
d'accord avec toi
louis qui dit une des meilleures saisons
au scoring que j'ai vu en entier c'est
vrai qu'il avait beaucoup de
responsabilités plus de 30% des usages
et il tournait quand même 1 après 2 56%
trou shooting et les 41% à 3 points
enfin bref c'était une sautée inquiétant
sur lancer-franc quand même s'était
inquiété
effectivement c'était un peu le des
marchés
d'ailleurs on dit souvent qu'il faut pas
oublier ça dans l'évaluation shooting
ben toi tu y croyait fort a marqué le
feu c'est ce que tu es d'accord avec ma
nièce que les sixers l'ont tué ou est-ce
qu'il était finalement pas si simple que
ça
j'étais bataille celui de tout un moyen
marque en force mais les rays lesquels
il a fait part à kara ont aucunement
rapport avec les rêves pour lesquels j 3
c'est à dire que je trouvais que c'est
un joueur qui était ma foi très chasse
pour y chercher des points mais qu'ils
n'avaient pas nécessairement un très
gros impact sur son équipe puis qui sait
pour qui deux points très bon foot alors
comme on dit en anglais
qui était pesé pour bien paraître ses
équipiers particulièrement qui n'était
pas vraiment capable de supporter pour
l'équipe pour être capable enfin gagner
mais rien tout seul ne s'est avéré
pertinent au
parcours de notre cas de forte chez les
pros l'histoire du chou moi l'histoire
que j'ai entendu parce que plusieurs
histoires avant toute chose de marques
fortes c'est que lui marc a travaillé
avec un spes
doctor who have a drame que père se
connaissaient ce sont huit qu'il y ait
des faits son shoot et plusieurs
personnes accusent john qui
venait
d'avoir
voir des fait son chou mais c'est pas
lui c'est pas deux jours elle même parce
que c'est pas un essai de réparer ils
sont toute l'année suivante mais ils
l'ont sorti jeudi rejoindre les sections
trois semaines après le début de la
saison et elle l'a dit il y pas prêt et
ses soeurs je crois qu
il se cherche on table atteint le record
de sa crise et là le vrai bon mais
écoute bluetooth
très bien et on accueille le chef d'
avait vu le chef qui arrivait
salut les gars libe tu vas ça va ça fait
plaisir de retrouver les anciens c'est
cool salut a tous un micro de boer il
nous met la mi-mai la lisière écoute
après après dix ans on a investi quand
nous toujours pas mais c'est vraiment
pour garder un peu ce côté champêtre
je comprends ouais
jb attend ben j b on est en train de
parler de markale folds toi toi toi tu
en penses quoi de cette légende de des
sixers qui l'ont
donc tu es tout à fait d'accord avec
manu vraiment sûr
sur la confiance et c'est pas une c'est
pas une force dès 6 heures en ce moment
à mais depuis quelques années de
protéger ses propres joueurs de les
mettre en confiance etc
il a été très exposé on a publié
énormément de vidéos de tous ces
entraînements de la façon dont ils
travaillent et son shoot
des en fait c'est première semaine
c'est clair que son pourcentage aux
lancers aurait pu nous alerter moi
j'aime beaucoup le joueur en fait parce
que il a une super science du basket il
l'a montré sa troisième saison à orlando
c'est un
fait une saison universitaire offensive
sentiment qui est dingue
même en nba et il a pu le montrer fait
quand même 72 matchs à sa troisième
saison
c'est vrai que ça fait un bail qui n'a
pas joué mais c'est un très beau joueur
qui malheureusement absolument a été
jeté un petit peu en pâture aux médias
qui sont très compliqués à philadelphie
en plus le dé tous des biches whiting un
fils et des filles est cruelle et
malheureusement ça lui a coûté je sais
pas si ça lui a coûté son épaule comme
tu dit manu mais en tout cas je pense
qu' énormément de fatigue mentale et
psychologique
qui n'ont pas forcément aidé avec sa
fatigue physique
romains eux
quand on refait le tir d'un joueur alors
ça aurait été évidemment parfait d'avoir
les spécialistes qu'on a eu par le passé
les l'eia sydney jo gomis pour parler de
ça mais mais mais toi tu en parles bien
aussi quand on refait le tir d'un joueur
par ou faut commencer et ce qu'on est ce
qu on refait tout depuis le début est ce
qu'on est ce qu on fait des bêtises
ajustement tient ton cou d'un peu plus
par là comment on fait pour éviter ce
genre de problème c'est à dire la ce a
même carrément une blessure donc c'est à
dire que c'est quand même assez violent
voilà là je suis en train de regarder ce
stade je me suis envoyé des à l'aide de
l'époque de l'époque à la fac là quand
pendant pendant vous échanger son tir
était pas très beau mais ce n'était pas
forcément non plus un drame si un drame
absolu comme on a pu voir chez l'autre
son volume de tirs pris quand il a la fa
qui n'est pas c'est correct il y à
125 125 tirs pris la 3 ans 25 matches
comme ça veut pas ça fait 5 par match un
peu plus donc le volume il est cohérent
même s'ils savaient y avait plus
tendance à attaquer le cercle et
compagnie il a 41 % à ce moment là
le problème le problème quand tu
commences à toucher aux tirs c'est que
c'est une question d'équilibré en fait
tu sais que tu vas bouger quelque chose
sur la chaîne qui
niveau de l'exécution dire autre chose
qui va se dérégler ainsi de suite il
faut trouver le moment où tu vas être
capable de d'arriver sur une espèce de
compromis entre tous les trucs que tu va
corriger qui va rendre ça qui va rendre
sa efficace la difficulté c'est si là
dedans tu rajoutes du travail du travail
musculaire spécifique c'est bien mais il
faut voir comment tu le fais vous voir
comment tout et cordell en fait le
travail de tir aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que comme énormément d'aspects
d'aspects techniques que tu vas
travailler au basket une vraie
transversalité donc
moi je pense qu'arriver à un certain âge
et 10 touchés c'est pas forcément
évident
vouloir le changer ça l'est encore moins
là effectivement l'adresse aux lancers
n'était pas allaiter pas dingue mais bon
après il ya eu une année de la ddn cielo
tu gères quand même tu gères un constat
sur des données totalement brut et puis
sans avoir droit - recul énorme
je pense que prendre le risque comme ils
l'ont fait c'est quelque chose
il faut voir après ce que je peux avoir
comme conséquences et si si les
blessures sont vraiment liées à sa
effectivement c c c est ce que le jeu en
vaille la chandelle moi c'est pas par dj
mercredi à qui on a demandé de changer
son souhaite aussi parce que sans
release était avec le pouce
c'est avec ces le pouce qui faisait la
direction du ballon choix qu'on lui a
demandé de changer son songe et sa
gestuelle une fois arrivée en nba
pas si vous à défendre j'aime ça mais
pourrait en plus de ça sur le terrain
non j'ai pas à ce jeu-là l'anecdote
village là je la connais pas à moi là
dessus sur ce sursaut tout cas je
n'avais pas entendu mais effectivement
tous ces petits gestes parasites le
problème c'est qu'on ne se rend compte
que ainsi pour le pour les plus anciens
rappelez-vous de chez marc daou et tim
hardaway n'était pas nécessairement un
installateur à proprement parler mais il
y avait un tir un tir qui était pas très
académiques la main était quasiment au
dessus
empêcher l'état d'être un scoreur
relativement prolifique dans sa carrière
est de réussir à faire quelque chose il
s'est toujours on est beaucoup plus
capable aujourd'hui avec là encore une
fois l'expertisé qu'on est con les
coachs de développement individuel les
players dave et puis les préparateurs
physiques et compagnie moi beaucoup plus
de terres pas citer aujourd'hui
peut-être avait fait rigoler ces choses
là mais il est toujours il ya toujours
un risque passer à certains moments de
doit retravailler sur la vie et la
gestion et l'exécution la mémoire
musculaire avec ses terrasses ce sera
une belle question opposé nicolas lang
continent journaux gratuits en commun
pour un prochain podcast pour voir son
avis un petit peu parce que l'on lui ça
reste un expert du tire donc autant
demander aux gens qui
dansaient le métier quelque part de
donner leur avis
je fais question à tous les quatre est
ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut passer à
travers les mailles du filet avec un
shoot comme ça déréglé dans la formation
justement c'est à dire que au bout d'un
moment un 13 14 ans et à ce moment là
que ça se règle très tôt entre les états
unis l'europe est ce que c'est encore
possible d'avoir un shoot atypique à 19
ans aujourd'hui oui parce que tu as des
joueurs qui pendant très longtemps de
parts d'une part la faiblesse des
championnats jeunes en france quelqu'un
de par la faiblesse de l'opposition sur
les championnats jeunes attention ou une
domination qui va être axé sur la
dimension physique ou sur des données
des données sur des qualités techniques
qui font qu'ils seront assez simple qui
sont très souvent sur le drive fut
averti qualité ou même simplement sur
l'agressivité tant que tu n'as pas
besoin du tir tu les vois pas et quelque
part c'est un petit peu le job aussi le
double des coaches qui font pas
forcément sur développement parce qu'à
un moment on veut gagner des matches on
s'en fout sauf que moi c'est l'exemple
que j'ai ce que je me souvent un joueur
d'un mètre quatre-vingt un certain âge
rien ne dit qu'il va jouer près du
cercle c'est pour ça que je fais partie
modestement des gens qui bat quel que
soit le profil j'ai toujours fait courir
les gens fait tirer les gens quand on
traîne sur les petites catégories
notamment notamment u12 u13 par louis
xiii berjamin j'ai beaucoup entre les
six catégories là que je trouve super
intéressant je pars du principe qu'il ya
un joueur qui sort d'un cursus de
benjamin lui est capable de courir de
s'arrêter et tirs et il sait faire c'est
trois choses là tu peux tout construire
dessus citons joueur ne sait pas où
courir ou s'arrêter ou tirer c'est
compliqué quel que soit le profil de
taille site à ces trois composants qui
sont réunis tu peux aller vers des
choses plus importantes et aux niveaux
pré collectif qui doit être sûre des
choses très simples sur des surnombres
sur des situations comme ça t'as pas
besoin de faire plus il faut pas qu'ils
font pas dans une espèce de fantasme
transfert du milieu où tu va organiser
les choses avant a vendu 18 ça ne marche
pas c'est d'essayer de voir si mais
l'évolution et le plafond thürer sur tes
joueurs tu vas le baisser par rapport à
l'exigence que tu vas mettre qui ne sera
pas adapté au niveau qui entraîne donc
oui pour répondre à ta question de
manière simple ce que je viens de faire
encore une digression de de diminuer tu
peux passer à travers les mailles du
filet oui si t'as pas dire c'est comme
tout quand utilisent un ordinateur tu me
dira jamais 100% l'aigle à la capacité
d'ordinateurs sur le plan sur le plan
technique et technologique tu veux
utiliser pendant direct et en fonction
de ce dont tu as besoin avec un ge avec
un joueur que tu développes c'est pareil
tu si tu n'as pas toi la perspective de
dire que tu doit cocher certaines cases
pour son développement et que tu adaptes
son utilisation à tes besoins
et tu te retrouves avec des gens
comparent à cons parce qu'il faut pour
passer l'écueil
manu ben vous avez des exemples de
joueurs draftés récemment qui achoppe
folklorique pour répondre à jb très mal
pour gueugnon
corriger le signe là mais l'eau jusqu'à
un certain point aussi mais ils sont
arrivés avec la
benne siemens je sais pas si c'était
d'accord avec l'idée de cabanes seven
chuterait avec la mauvaise main c'est
comme une espèce de théories du complot
sur les réseaux sociaux je sais pas à
quoi passer par moi même
il ya un truc qui un truc qu'il faut
intégrer aussi et ça encore une fois je
suis pas expert mais des gens comparent
au mieux que moi il ya deux composantes
il ya les préférences motrices qui font
qu'il ya des choses que les gens peuvent
faire ou pas de toute façon c'est
intrinsèque et si on ne peut pas ne pas
trop changer et puis est-ce qu'il ya si
nous avait expliqué que yannick et les
préférences oculaire très souvent les
gens qui titille qui tirent sur des
profits sur des profils en fait ils vont
franchir la vue du corps avec la balle
est plutôt désaxé les choses comme ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle les profits
croisé et il ya des adaptations très
précise à faire en fonction de ces
choses là on peut avoir deux types de
profils un rejet de croiser et en
fonction de ça on doit travailler une
certaine façon ou d'une autre après
l'histoire de ben simons on en revient
toujours à ses pareils il ya c'est le
serpent qui se mord la queue yéménites
des limites qui tient mentale parce que
le mec doute de son tir parce qu'ils
voient pas d'efficacité entière et puis
à tout ce que tu peux ou pas construire
dessus était liée à sa limite profil
croisés pour décrypter ce était droitier
ton ifor c'est le gauche ça ouais c'est
ça et c'est tous les gestes ou tu voir
tendance en fait à partir plus tôt sur
des gestuelles où tu vas être simplement
dessus tu va croiser et on axe avant de
tirer pour faire très simple ça
schématiser et récemment chez place si
celle ci a été drafté mais il est border
g-league et je pense qu'il va réussir à
percer un jour un biais très bling
queens
de new mexico state s'est fait rire ben
tu avais cherché celui-là
qui est qu'ils avaient un shoot à un
petit peu particuliers aussi j'ai pas
fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu jouer
donc je sais pas s'il a gardé le même
s'il a modifié etc mais très belle
transition avec la réponse des frères
ball puisque l'oms au bol était le choix
numéro deux de cette grâce donc on va
beaucoup parler tout évidemment
continuer à dire
même question ben est ce que toi tu
l'aurais pris en deux est-ce que tu
l'aurais pris aussi aux est-ce que tu
croyais moi je sais que c'est ma plus
grande erreur d'évaluation je pense de
cette draft là
à moi j'y croyais moi je pensais qu'il
était valait un top3 facilement alors
que lundi c'est un très bon joueur mais
je pense pas que ça vaut un taux de 3 où
je pense que ça des miracles pas dans
cette grappe mats et donovan mitchell
balle un débat you did
we je suis d'accord mais tu sais il ya
beaucoup de ces joueurs là qui ont
qu'ils ont battus
qu'ils ont battu les cotes à vegas pour
ce pur données qui sont devenus
aujourd'hui d'en bas hamad et bayod qui
c'est une situation à miami mitchell qui
lui qui était sous l aile de johnny
bryant auteur qui était vraiment et mais
landreau partout où il va partout avec
qui joue les joies produits moi je
trouve que le dos un joueur qu'on qu'on
ne comble pas ça comprendre avec ses
stats qui font qu'on voit un peu
tout ce qui se passe autour de lui moi
je crois que quand même plus ou moins
lui doit la moitié de tout le savoir qui
a fait chez les professionnels parce que
si longue et si tu regardes la première
saison de 4 pouces - où il fait je crois
16 points par match on l'envoie dépenses
donc moi le zoo si j'étais à l'époque
encore je leur ai drafté numéro deux
patrick mêmes numéros
sans vécu ni
le jason day tombe d'ailleurs qui était
aussi une réserve
manu sur l'endos bol on remet dans le
contexte c'est ce que tu peux nous
rappeler saison incroyable à ucla moi
c'est l'équipe que je préfère regarder
jouer c'était génial
ouais c'est un joueur assez formidable à
regarder aussi et qui rendait les autres
meilleures options d'un mini débat qu'on
a vu avec avec antoine et l'époque on
disait ça il rend les autres meilleurs
en fait lui est bon pas me rendais les
autres ultras meilleur il a fait une
saison incroyable avec ucla je crois
qu'il les emmène au
march madness qui ils font pas très très
loin mais il les emmène
et il est notamment le niveau qi basket
à la passe il est incroyable et je suis
d'accord avec ben pour moi il mérite 2
c'est peut-être beaucoup mais il mérite
un top 5 en tout cas je trouve qu'il a
il l'a réussi en plus à ce ass revisité
il est arrivé dans une équipe des lakers
flamande moribonde à l'époque
après il a pas eu de bol il est tombé
sur sur le brand qui le virent plus ou
moins
donc nouvelle orléans s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé c'est un pas en marasme
aussi et là il retrouve dans une équipe
qui est à son niveau à chicago il est
très bon ce soit en défense ou en
attaque comme dubaï où il rend encore
les payeurs et je trouve ça moi je
trouve ça assez assez dingue ce genre de
joueur même s'il est pas flashy ou quoi
ou moins que son frère ou moins quand
des matchs carrière flash et un ayew om
est mignon petit
groupe
environnement - flashy maintenant avec
les bulls qu'il était à ucla où il était
en risque ou en fête ou de l'aoueille la
chaîne était pas ça c'est dingue des
fois ça y est il est revenu joueur de
basket en fait vraiment vraiment meneur
d'hommes meneur de jeu et c'est je
trouve assez intéressant de le fait
qu'il sait plus ou moins réinventer et
intelligemment pour réussir dans une
équipe bien construite déjà et avec des
joueurs qui le correspondant fait et le
candidat note oddo dit qu il a réussi
aussi à changer chouchouter sa salle e
ça lui donne une arme en plus parce
qu'avant les joueurs il laissait plus ou
moins choqué parce qu'il savait que ça
allait pas rentrer je crois il avait
moins de 30% et réussit à issia les noms
mais justement il y aussi hélas il
shoote bien à trois points mais il a un
pour un west ham aux lancers-francs way
justement il fait une fait une saison
trompe l'oeil à ucla à 41 % 1 3 point
sur un fort volume il en coûte 190 dans
l'année mais la ligne est plus proche
mais là des joueurs autour de lui qui
lui permettent de prendre ces tirs aussi
plusieurs remarques de hughes dans le
chatt notre hub qui gère notre notre
chaîne twitch à envergure on vous invite
à aller suivre
qui nous dit d'abord qu'il est
probablement un profil croisé puisqu'il
a un choc dégueulasse donc on attend les
vidéos et et plus sérieusement
ty gélif lui doit un premier tour et ça
il a complètement raison c'est un truc
que j'avais un côté petit gélif qui lors
de cette draft est choisi je crois
17-18 par indiana
et il ya aussi au 2e tour ike annick
borgo qui est le pivot de mes joueurs
jouent si elle est hyper hyper mobile et
tout mais je crois qu'il avait pas deux
genoux en fait il avait perdu un genou
cours de route quoi et du coup il n'a
jamais percé j'ai vérifié aujourd'hui de
quoi du land nous depuis javier ont ce
dernier
il bosse à la bibliothèque
aptitudes gélif d'ailleurs a été plutôt
drafté par l'épaisseur soir ce qui
s'appelait tidjane ans était une
franchise qui a fait jouer pas mal de
tiges et en même temps et trois
étoiles
6 et le petit jet je peux tu peux y
arriver c'était un projet
pour ton prochain fils jb faut l'appeler
dj quoi tu sais ce qu'il a à faire c'est
exactement un investissement important
et donc l'autre
l'autre chose que nous dit hughes dans
le chat c'est c'est au niveau du
contexte
jb le contexte lakers est ce que tu
penses qu'il a desservi l'on nous au bol
pour les premières années
alors ça va vous paraître surprenant
mais pas tant que ça
n'était pas le bon moment des lakers
étaient pas évidemment le meilleur
roster la meilleure saison etc mais il
est allé dans une ville où son père
voulait absolument qu'il soit on se
rappelle un de big bear the border et
c'était d'ailleurs assez insupportable
toute la hype qui entourait cette
famille avant l'arrivée de mon dos et
depuis ça c'est ça c'est bien tassée
et finalement je pense que ça lui a été
plutôt utile ça lui était plutôt utile
pour apprendre
en nba alors de traits de la gnognotte à
la nouvelle orléans a été plus compliqué
je pense et pourtant ça lui a redonné sa
chance et sur une énorme saison à la
nouvelle orléans mais
ça lui a donné du temps ça lui a donné
des responsabilités il joue assez peu et
vous quasiment que des moitiés de saison
mais c'est pas c'est pas un contexte si
négatif que ça honnêtement c'est là
plutôt construits et aujourd'hui à
chicago c'est évidemment le roster et et
mieux construits moi je me suis vous
vous dites que vous êtes trompés sur des
joueurs dans les bars moi je me suis
trompé sur chicago cette année je les
dis je les ai dit tout à l'heure où il
ya quelques jours mais je trouve ça je
trouve ça assez bien pour pour lui pour
commencer dans une dans une ville où il
y avait beaucoup de hype et on attendait
un peu comme le messie a surtout pic 2
mais en fait c'était pas si
problématique que ça honnêtement
il ya ce truc du tir donc ma nuque
disait pendant longtemps il a eu il a
été bloqué aujourd'hui c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs en spots up en spots
ap en nba
romain je sais je pense que l'on nous on
était un profil croisés à l'époque
puisqu'il est vraiment ce geste qui
partaient sur notre épaule
alors si c'est pas imaginer que c'est
pas des choses qui changent donc il doit
toujours l'être mais
pardon n'en soit pas un truc que tu peux
changer c'est qu'il ya des choses que tu
peux faire évoluer certains détails mais
ce n'est pas quelque chose que tu peux
changer maintenant il a réussi à
stabiliser à stabiliser ce tir
est-ce que c'est plus facile
quand enfin en gros qu'une question
hyper difficile que je te pose mais bon
tu sais je te mets je te mets toujours
des petits bâtons dans les roues pour
que tu puisses camp s'était dit certain
sion je vais parler trois heures ainsi
c'est difficile
comment on fait pour parce que l'on zoo
à la base il a la balle il a la balle
parce qu'il est fort avec et parce que
il fait des passes parfaites et ça je
maintiens que des dix dernières années
je pense que c'est le meilleur passeur
simple que j'ai vu moi en nba c'est à
dire les passes elle arrive pile au bon
endroit dans vraiment dans la shooting
populaire de la personne donc il a le
ballon il shoote avec la balle mais je
joue pas très bien on sortit dribbles et
on le fait devenir un spotters shooter
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et ce que est
ce que c est ce que c'est difficile
parce que c'est plus difficile que dans
l'autre sens par exemple
puisqu'en fait il a eu le ballon toute
sa vie puisque le gosse il était doué
depuis qu'il y avait 13 14 ans avant ça
t'a beaucoup de joueurs en fait qu'ils
ont
sinon
comment dia
qui vont être beaucoup plus à l'aise sur
le rythme quand il y en a pas loin c'est
pour ça que tu as beaucoup mais
finalement qui qui vont être des très
bons joueurs de poulet mais moins
contraint même sur des tribus rapide des
choses comme ça parce que pour certains
profils c'est plus facile
tu vois donc quand tu es un joueur de
bouloc au départ devenir un joueur spots
up
c'est quand même quelque chose de ces
comme quelque chose de tordu parce que
de tordus non mais de cesser ses jeux
faire du jean claude van damme parce
qu'à force de parler anglais toute la
journée chez le monde anglais et en
français mais c'est c'est c'est pas
simple parce que c'est pas c'est pas ben
tu sais de quoi je parle quand je dis ça
comme suit celle de l'anglais au
français du tout qu'on pense que je la
ccc bassin après derrière c'est très
souvent une question de rythme il ya
tout un travail que tu peux faire qui
travaille de près par xp ci fixe sur le
bas du corps sur leurs activités sur
l'explosion bonne chose mais la clé tout
sur le tir si le rythme malgré tout
c'est d'être capable d'être en rythme et
quand tu sais de mettre en rythme avec
la balle et tu le sais c'est pas fort tu
sais moi aussi donc de 300 la balle de
même que tu as des joueurs qui seront d
d excellent tireur de spotter mais qui
vont galérer pour se battre au rythme
parce que ce sera pas pareil donc encore
une fois tu es sur des choses que tu
peut optimiser
à moins sûr il fut exceptionnelle tu
peux vraiment au big red et complet mais
j'en reviens suis tout à l'heure le
plafond il est souvent lié à des limites
techniques que tu peux faire évoluer à
tes limites physiques que dans sa simple
dans une large proportion tu peux faire
évoluer mais également après et c'est
pas une maraude chez moi mais c'est ce
sera bien qu'un jour on est l'occasion
de discuter avec les termes ancien
vraiment la spécialité et les
promotrices jeu j'en parle souvent dans
le cas des joueurs intérieurs tu as des
mails tu dis mais je comprends pas il a
jamais allé finir sur cette main où il
n'arrive jamais spin est sûre cette
épaule
moi je me suis fais profil et plein de
fois où je sais comment je suis j'ai vu
des joueurs se faire profiler j'ai eu à
l'intérieur une fois un joueur intérieur
il était incapable de tourner sur une
épaule et c'était ridicule c'est à dire
que quand on cote quand on voit pas le
joueur qui était ridicule mais c'est le
contexte et j'ai un peu le même souci
dire que c'est des gens qui sont fiers
de faire la rotation dans un sens et
qu'ils ne pourront pas la faire dans
l'autre et qu'ils vont prendre le chemin
le plus long pour faire la rotation dans
l'autre sens je sais pas si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et pour en revenir à
ces histoires de construction tire on a
parfois ses limites là et c'est des
choses qui à 5 10 15 ans quand ce
n'était pas ce n'était pas maîtrisée
comme celle et aujourd'hui on n'avait
pas la capacité à dire tiens c'est
peut-être tel ou tel truc qui on n'avait
pas le détail et est aujourd'hui comme
on avance sur cette connaissance là la
transversalité permet de changer des
choses et à ccc des trucs qui sont
utilisés aujourd'hui
sur les équipes de foot à très haut
niveau le rubis un petit peu le basket
français très en retard sur ces choses
là il ya peu de gens qui s'en sert
vraiment en hindi et bien sûr il ya de
la vence mais il ya un tel comment dire
il ya un tel
une telle marge de progression qu'on
pourrait trouver dans la capacité à
entraîner en maîtrisant ça c'est un truc
auquel mon collègue front tu ne
s'intéressent beaucoup comme yacine à
limoges de fait aussi on a quelqu'un qui
était venu présenter un travail
justement sur l'épreuve que tristan
dernier en fin de saison nous avait
expliqué avec sur plusieurs joueurs et
de billets sur le fait que certains
joueurs vont être capables par exemple
d'attraper sur la gauche est tirée
directement look d'autres ne pourront
pas certains jours vous en être en
mouvement d'aller vers la balle leur
pourcentage de réussite sera très élevé
dans ces situations là s'ils s'éloignent
de la balle pour des raisons de presse
motrices et oculaires ce sera pareil
donc il ya tellement de détails qui font
que l'idéal et finalement c'est de
connaître ses joueurs d'être capable de
d'optimiser les choses au mieux et
surtout je pense la clé après c'est
d'utiliser les mecs dans leur zone
d'efficacité n'a plus la plus forte elle
a avancé et encore une fois je suis
parti loin et cédant 1 c'est dans un
monde absolu mais il ya aussi mais ça
c'est ce que ça rejoint un peu ce que
disait jb dans le sens tu me dis j b si
je me trompe mais dans le sang ce
contexte pas si mauvais que ça c'est à
dire ils l'ont utilisée avec ses forces
il a joué quatre ans il a joué 35
minutes ouais enfin par match sur une
année
c'est ça c'est ça mais après derrière
c'est l'éternel est presque on développe
les points forts et les points faibles
d'une part et puis la khl il pourra
jouer devoir c'est y joue malgré tout
c'est qu'ils ont
développée par le csa et puis bon c'est
35 minutes dans un contexte qui n'était
pas forcément inintéressant
la saison de qui je le mets les stades
sous les yeux il ya 10 points 10 points
7 rebonds 7 rebonds 7 passes on a de
pire quand même à trois points c'est à
30% c'est pas extraordinaire c'est pas
non plus une
écologie calabar autour des 30 pour le
premier rookie pour ces joueurs là c'est
pas parfait mais c'est pareil tu sais
que c'est un joueur ce sera jamais un
sniper ce sera jamais un tireur d'élite
mes partenaires
non mais voilà maintenant aujourd'hui
autour de 37 ces joueurs là s'y passe de
30 à 37 38 cc c'est plus pareil et c'est
plus pareil je sais jamais ce sera
jamais quelques erreurs tu le sais mais
par contre il est capable d'apporter du
danger la base du rebond un petit petit
exter s'il fait un petit peu tous
magnifiques pour de magie de ben qui
vient de disparaître
si l'idée n'est pas de faire mieux au
bout d'un quai de saint gilles à arriver
non c'est moi je pense que la clé la clé
un petit peu là qu'il est bon j'ose
croire que vu le boulot faire tu rascar
niches va se sur la reconstruction à
chicago et le rendement de l'équipe
cette année on
pense pas qu'il soit trompé tant que ça
un payet new orleans c'est une équipe
qui peine un petit peu dans le temps à
se reconstruire mais qui qu'un front
office qui est quand même composé de
gens de jean utile et intéressant et
intelligent capable d'évaluer compagnie
donc je pense pas qu'ils soient capables
de tenir longtemps comme ça s'il ya pas
d'une part la marge de progression et si
c'était pas un vrai joueur derrière le
fait d'avoir laissé tous les utiliser un
anglicisme je suis désolé mais tout
shipshaw los angeles avec avec tout ce
bazar thiel autour du père de ceci de
cela bizarrement le mec a quand même
c'était pas un petit peu derrière et
c'est pas il est intéressant donc
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai sable c'est
pas plus mal que son frère arrive soit
arrivé aussi dans un contexte apaisé en
tout cas moins moins exposés du côté de
charlotte on salue tous les amis qui
sont arrivés au compte-gouttes dans le
tchat vous avez des questions n'hésitez
pas on les prendra dans la mesure du
possible
ben pour finir sur l'oms au bol il ya
une comme commence à nous ça peut nous
apprendre des choses sur les draft à
venir ou sur les draft en cours
u10 est un truc tout à l'heure dans le
tchat le problème c'est son premier pas
est en fait il ya un indicateur assez
assez facile pour ça pour pour savoir si
un joueur est assez athlétique pour
faire des différences par lui même c'est
le nombre de lancers francs provoquée
c'est à dire le fruit
et l'oms au bol il était à moins de 30
c'est à dire que pour pour 10 tirs pris
ils prenaient moins de trois lancers
francs et
et moi 30 c'est ma limite aujourd'hui
en règle générale en tout cas pour les
arrières
dans la draft je me méfie quand ce taux
il est en dessous de 30 est ce que toi
aussi ce concept de mettre de la
pression sur le cercle c'est comme ça
que ça a été théorisé en tout cas c'est
de ces dernières années ce que ça cette
influence dans dans tes choix dans ses
évaluations de draft aujourd'hui ben ça
dépend ça dépend de wes qu'on classe le
joueur ça dépend de qu'est-ce qu'on
s'attend du joueur il ya beaucoup une
fois la sic on fait beaucoup dans le
draft c'est que on s'imagine qu'un
joueur au collège je vais avoir le même
rôle en billets souvent les équipes
draft avec une idée précise et qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent qu'un joueur devient et
comme disait romain
le noble il nous fait jouer avec ses
forces puis c'est pas un joueur qui met
justement de la pression spa joueurs
d'appoint ce joueur qui qui ont besoin
de quelqu'un d'autre pour mettre la
pression sur
sur la langue pilote à chicago il la zac
la viny l'admr de lausanne qui pend sauf
pour lui et ce soir je crois que c'est
oui c'est vraiment un handicap 1 mais
c'est un éducateur un pape ait amara 15
juin il pas moi qui désole c'est mon
chien qui accroche de la sorte la porte
c'est
[Rires]
c1
c'est oui c'est comme la différence
entre un bon joueur nba conjoint les
deux billets comme la zone rouge parce
que je le répète ce joueur que j'aime
beaucoup ce joueur je crois qu'à travers
n'importe quelle équipe de billets marin
et mais c'est très différent sans
provoquer des choses plus cheap ou
jetons m'entraîner numériquement son
équipe
c'est un très bon joueur de contexte
doudou d'où mon affirmation de base qui
disaient que je m'étais trompé parce que
quand tu choisis un top3 tu choisi
quelqu'un qui va être le leader de ton
équipe et qui va aller chercher des
points sur la ligne des lancers francs
quand il faut et il
a changé qui va changer quelque chose
chez toi
samuel samuel nous pose une question
est ce que l'on nous a souffert d'une
hyper médiatisation une trop grosse hype
avant d'arriver en
nba manu qu'est ce que t'en pense et ce
que pour toi ça ça peut desservir un
joueur d'avoir une trop grosse hype moi
je répondrais je pas d'accord
un peu mais si hype qui l'a pas
forcément fin qu'il a subie en fait
totalement ou c'est son père qui faisait
sa promotion vous voyez des fois si on
dirait des shows télé ou où l'on nous au
il arrive avec son daron mais il tirait
la tête quoi qu'est ce que fout là en
gros et il a totalement subi ça je
trouvais le fait de l'enfant de
l'envoyer à los angeles ça a été un peu
moins chaud avec un show et du coup ça
c'est pas la bonne potion
et le dé qui s'est un peu séparé de son
père dans sa dans sa gestion eh ben on a
vu qu'il le joueur a les boules mais en
fait ça correspond plus ou moins aux
halles échanges avec la nouvelle orléans
on retrouve un joueur épanoui en fait
tout simplement faim moi c'est comme ça
je n'ai perçu serment le son père qu à
absorber le tout l'image et à envoyer
way mon fils il est trop fort beau fils
il est trop fort et eux ce qui n'a pas
forcément fait avec son frère la mélo
qui finalement est bon quasiment tout de
suite
moi je trouve pas qu'il a été ouais mais
il a moins été présents avaient clamés
look avec l'eau avec l'oms au il était
tout le temps présent il n'arrêtait pas
de parler oui c'est le meilleur ou c'est
le meilleur fouquet huit mois avant la
draft qui lie aux lakers ou ko lakers
faut absolument qu'il a eue les qui
reçoit c'est insupportable en fait alors
qu'elle est je pense qu'elle va les
caractères manu il ya des caractères et
le zoo effectivement pas forcément le
caractère de tenir ce genre de pression
mise que ce soit par son père par les
médias ou par les mecs qui ont regardé
une saison de ouf à ucla aussi son frère
paraît avoir beaucoup plus les épaules
pour ça mais on rappelle du cheap show
et j'emprunte le mo de rom un merci
quand il l'envoie en lituanie quand même
la mélo il est pas sorti blanc vous
n'avez l'envoi en australie et c'est
n'importe quoi tu vois et pourtant le
gars aujourd'hui il a les épaules il
fait une carrière costaud je pense à une
question de caractère j'ai une anecdote
à ce sujet les frères baud lors je ne
sais pas si c'est vrai et je demanderai
je demanderai aux intéressés de le
confirmer mais il y avait eu une
approche et je crois que c'est nico
qu'on avait parlé une fois et c'était
passé un peu soir entre par rapport aux
frères baud pour que quand ils sont
partis les corps cirque en lituanie là
bas et une approche et que le club du
ccrb à châlons reims à l'époque et
j'aurais adoré voir ce bazar les bébés
seraient absolument fabuleux mais oui
mais oui je me rappelle
lorsque la libye en ligue 1 ne
l'oublions pas bien c'est ça de l'oubli
n'était plus à nous aimer le à deux
doigts de la champagne a besoin d'un
champagne ce soir seraient tels travaux
mais surtout près de paris sur été
fabuleux parce que le club me suis
retrouvée qui était au fin fond de la
lituanie qu'un pays que j'adore c'était
trop dernier en rougir en vacances
moi après d'autres pays qu'on pas
d'accord d'extradition avec la france
mais ça c'est un autre problème
géopolitique mais là pour le coup je
rejoins ton je rejoins tonton ce que ce
que vous voulez dire moi moi je vois les
premières interviews je vois je vois le
zoo avec le père et j'ai l'impression
voir ces situations ou quand je coachais
désespoir ou des cadets ou des cannettes
vous avez des parents débile dans les
tribunes
et les gamins sur le banc qui avait on
peut entendre les parents et c'est
quelque chose que
j'ai vu la même chose sauf que là la ccc
décuplée par le parlement s'est
amplifiée ou tout ce que vous voulez
parler par le côté médiatique et
compagnie là on a juste un espèce de
gros abrutis qui ne sait pas gérer ses
émotions dix échecs perso qui gère son
fils c'est incroyable incroyable
incroyable de malaise et de
puis j'ai envie de dire même si on n'est
pas là pour ça appuie d'anti éducation
c'est une catastrophe dans la recherche
d'autonomie tu vas tu vas essayer de
keke but ultime de tout sportif de tout
athlète cessé d'aller vers l'autonomie
generali c'est un cas d'école je pense
surtout à entendre sur plein de sueur
sur plainte de l'aspect psychologique un
peu comme ça
mais pour répondre et pour finir sur
lonzo pour répondre à samuel
moi j'estime pour des joueurs comme
l'oiseau en tout cas c'est à dire qu'ils
font leur cursus aux aux états unis
généralement les types on a l'exemple
avec les mots ni bates samuel de chat
cité hand williamson
des mecs qu'on la pression dès qu'ils
ont 14 15 ans d'ailleurs qui se
retrouvent surtout maintenant avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire que là ils
vont se retrouver avec des des millions
d'abonnés sur un stade des suiveurs de
partout il la moindre vidéo va faire un
buzz les concernant et c'est
moi je considère que si un mec il arrive
à gérer ça à 15 16 ans qu'il arrive en
6e est qui fait son année et donc il est
drafté en nba en fait il l'a déjà la
pression il a réussi à maintenir un
niveau assez élevé pour drafté au malgré
cette pression pour moi c'est pas c'est
pas ça qui va faire de lui un mauvais
joueur quand ils arrivent en une billets
parce qu'il aura sur l'équitation
et c'est pour ça que je suis pas très
d'accord avec ceux qui disent que les
mots ni bates est en train de devenir un
énorme buzz c'est un joueur de memphis
dont on parlera lors de la prochaine
draft c'est beaucoup trop tôt
salut adrien le chat on embrasse ont ils
fait des bisous c'est lui qui a fait
notre notre nouveau notre nouveau logo
messieurs c'est des gros big
man u c'est à toi puisque je vous ai
demandé de préparer votre votre mea
culpa votre erreur de la draft manu key
qui as tu choisi qui avait tu qui a quel
joueur de cette grappe 2017 dont a
complètement raté l'évaluation à
l'époque
ce bon cher et driss et bam adebayo
qui a été sélectionné l'autre fin de
loterie 14e à miami et en fait je me
suis là sa saison kane qui m'a vraiment
bouleversée en mal
je le voyais vraiment dans un dans une
situation catastrophique où il pas un de
mes souvenirs ça fait ça à faire tout
quatre ans maintenant ou je le voyais
vrai qu'elle y paraît utiliser son
panier et basta quoi
que ce soit en attaque ou en défense
alors que j'ai des sites je l'avais vu
quelques j'avais vu quelques matchs et a
light quand j'étais au lycée et on
voyait un mec taper des spin move en
contre attaque effacé deux joueurs faire
des heureuses tête faire des trucs de
dingue
qu'on ne voyait plus du tout mcintee où
il était dans son rôle il était avec ma
guitare neufbox à l'époque je sais plus
trop l'équipe qu'ils avaient mon âge je
vois aussi
et je suis plus
allé à briscoe le fameux est en fait il
a kind qui il les entrées dans un groupe
beaucoup plus d'intérieur et en fait on
n'a pas vu ses qualités à clés qu'on
apprend si parce que ça c'est un buffle
met un on n'a pas vu fin moi en tout cas
j'ai pas vu ce qu'il fait actuellement à
miami d un joueur capable de défendre
sur quasiment toutes les positions un
joueur qui est devenu assez dingue je
trouve dans l'arène protection
moi j'avais pas vu sèche donc c'est pour
ça que pour moi l'erreur que j'ai faite
c'est joue un peu trop au mobilier par
sa l'année en pet est ancien alors que
j'aurais dû prendre en compte vraiment
tout ce que j'ai vu par le passé donc
high schools je sais pas vu thi nhu est
sèche qui savent bien qu'on m'a utile
mais c est l apprendre plusieurs
avions et les rencontres vraiment tous
ses matchs suite plusieurs saisons et
pas à garder un deux ans
ces deux dernières années en fait c'est
rarement sa benne est ce que toi tu
avais une évaluation différente
dattebayo et est-ce que regarder
plusieurs contextes ça t'a aidée pour
des joueurs après ou avant est ce qu'il
ya des exemples de joueurs qui viennent
en tête où ben en fait c'est en
regardant les matchs 2006 où les matches
internationaux qu'on pouvait imaginer
son rôle mais c'est sûr que ce qu'un
manu parle c'est pas vrai ce jeu c'est
un problème qui a un rapport à bas hamad
et bayod moi j'appelle ça le syndrome
kent et il sert aux kiwis tomber le plus
de possibles de joueurs il paraît
talentueux sur le terrain qu'on les
laisse se battre pour avoir des
possessions on se rappellera de déveine
bouquin qui était devenu un gars de
catch and shoot uniquement à cannes de
kiki et se développer en devenir un des
meilleurs joueurs nba moi jamais
j'avais vu ben debba you justement j'ai
vu les mêmes choses que manu au lycée
l'ascétisme quick to which these qui
était capable justement de de bouger
avec une vitesse absolument féline joie
ou est-ce que c'était impossible il y
avait des joueurs plus la quitter il
réfléchit dié même pas temps de
réfléchir ben hamad et bioware
de bouger une qualité athlétique qui est
vraiment
présente eu beaucoup de joueurs nba mais
pauvres impose nécessairement à un
dossier soit je savais qu'il était
capable de faire ça je le savais il est
capable de
de jouer
justement avec des avoirs les spin move
to death ou le fil hier toute seule
chose je savais qu'il est capable de
faire ça mais je crois que beaucoup
bénéficié du meilleur coach en nba
présentement qui acquit l'oeuf que je
crois il lui aurait essayé tout plein de
choses un truc avec avec erik spoelstra
à miami c'est qui fait essayer des
choses se jouent en il aimait dans
toutes sortes de situations il fait
toutes sortes de joueurs pour eux ils
décident dans l'euphorie et bam adebayo
là c'est un passeur
on attendait port puis
c'est justement ce un joueur qui bouge
beaucoup mieux en défensive que ce qu'on
croyait ce parce que parce que rx pour
la soyez essayer des choses avec lui
dans titre ça a été je crois que
athlétiquement et techniquement parloir
il ne bénéficie d'une excellente
situation pour lui-même
c'est dingue de voir que miami est une
excellente destination pour beaucoup de
joueurs sont drafté tard ou non drafté
d'ailleurs grâce à eric spoelstra
kim est vraiment qui crée un
environnement ultra positif son coaching
staff en termes de développement des
spécialités et romain en parlait tu
choisis ce que tu veux développer dans
les joueurs que tu es à ta disposition
et en l'occurrence à miami
minorée à beaucoup de réussite dans ce
sens là et bam adebayo vous faites
partie c'est à dire qu'on va continuer à
te former et de construire une carrière
nba grâce à la très forte en fait c'est
ça qui est assez impressionnant et
d'autre exemple plus récent évidemment
intérieur héros en fait partie duncan
zone aussi d'un canon le médecin n'a pas
encore plus loin dans la saison mais il
ya le prochain
il est fort nous tease g j'ai un chiffre
pour vous messieurs
4,7 c'est le pourcentage de passes
décisives de bama d ayo à kentucky
depuis une quinzaine d'années selon la
ba la base de données barque torts vic
les joueurs draftés dans le top-15 con
ce taux de passes décisives c'est
moubarak collins andré drummond larry
sanders
d'alejandro achim thabeet évidemment
jackson ait nos avants ne l'est adrian
payne donc 100 dinars jeté l'opprobre
pas que des réussites effectivement mais
lui sortait du lot grâce à ce film on
pouvait l'imaginer sortir du lot grâce à
ce film
regardons as cool elle va aussi un
article qu'il a longtemps laissé chez
plus il l'est toujours en en tweets
épinglé mais zac l'eau avait fait un
article pour parler de bam adebayo et de
son processus de draft est en fait ni a
misé en espèces de 2 drilles où ils
épuisent le joueur vraiment il alors je
sais pas à quel point c'est une légende
et tout le monde fait ça ou à quel point
c'est juste à miami coup mais ils
épuisent le joueur ils lui font faire
n'importe quoi enfin pas n'importe quoi
mais ils lui disent des trucs
impossibles quoi et il voit jusqu'où le
mec est capable d'aller de repousser ses
limites et de supporter
ses consignes assez absurde juste parce
qu'on lui dit de faire ça et ils disent
qu'il ya des bayonnais a tout démonté il
est resté plus longtemps que n'importe
qui et que à ce moment là ils ont su que
génétiquement mentalement
intellectuellement peut-être il était au
dessus de 9 joueurs de tuer jb tu vas
dire un truc ouais absolument je
représente jeune coline ce soir vous
l'avez vu
en 2010 est non juste un truc moi je
suis papa de deux jeunes enfants ma
fille dort toujours pas donc je vous
laisse les gars
il est à en france c'est vrai il est
tard quand on embrasse merci beaucoup
d'être passé quel est ton joueur préféré
l'adapt 2010 jibé alors ça va surprendre
monde clairement franck n'est liquida
d'affect non mais je suis ça y est je
suis sérieux en termes d'un fake de
caractère de profils de ski son jeu en
équipe de france aussi évidemment le
prince mais sinon de normal mitchell et
j'aimerais bien que je reviendrai vous
ré écouter sur de nomades mitchell qui
est quand même un joueur au delà de son
jeu au caractère et à la personnalité
absolument incroyable absolument de de
leadership de confiance en soi et puis
vous parlerez j'espère aussi de cette
série incroyable contre les nuggets il
ya deux ans est vraiment un joueur
merveilleux et je veux pas dire sous
côté lorsqu'on les utilise à tort et à
travers mais quelqu'un aussi une
personnalité une bière remarque à les
tarifs et les amis salut limbé merci et
à bientôt sur sur poster d'elle ouais ça
roule
romain se parler du drill de bam adebayo
la
dreale du miami heat est ce que pour toi
c'est la légende on peut construite
c'est à dire on va leur faire faire
n'importe quoi pendant le processus pré
draft pour faire ressortir les meilleurs
psychologiquement c'est un peu les idées
les entraînements pour intégrer les gi's
quoi et
alors tu es en mieux de termes ou de
termes minutes
alertme août alors il faut par podcast
mais ce qui gêne quand j'étais en train
de taper en même temps c'est pour çà
risque non vives et les déficits se
demander sur les sur les meilleurs des
meilleurs des meilleurs pour ce coup là
lé duo de choc pour la référence mais
peut-être jour là la partie un petit peu
un petit peu on recommence et l'histoire
fait sain psycho ce qu'on raconte sur
les joueurs c'est une première eid al
assad le dernier parti alors pensé
pendant l'année les mecs enfin quasiment
pas mais
je pense que quelque part
je regardais pas par curiosité
l'organigramme un petit peu de
duparc franchise du 8 voir s'ils étaient
ou en fait en 40 de casey compagnie et
l'histoire si elle est vraie nous
n'aurons qu'à moitié quand on sait ce
que parce que pat riley a pu faire à
faire un mur notamment
et à miami ensuite en terme de deux
d'exigence de dureté et compagnie ce
projet n'est pas forcément fan de
première année mais au final le mec
existe dans la durée et et parfois eu
des équipes pas forcément folichon
énergie à faire des choses je pense
qu'une vraie compétence la barre
et cette compétence il existe dans la
capacité à entraîner et affaires
provinciales et inévitablement ils
existent dans la capacité à évaluer or
parce qu'effectivement ils ont poussé
dans ses dernières limites que le mec
était exempt au sol et ainsi de suite je
ne sais pas mais met les gens en
situations
de switch émotionnel de stress et d'un
confort c'est sûrement la meilleure
façon possible de pouvoir les évaluer de
toute façon donc si c'est quelque chose
qui est faire intelligemment
dans le process d'évaluation que ses
caméras tupi comme on peut avoir à
certains moments
je pense que c'est quelque chose de très
intéressant
absolument pas renoncé - qui était en
mieux cette fois ça fait
manu tu tues tu disais donc bam tu
l'avais vu en high school mais peut-être
pas assez pris en compte cette année en
et school est ce qu'il ya des drames
depuis où
tu as tu as changé ton opinion sur un
joueur
grâce à au visionnage du film au lycée
ou
du film en international ou autre
sur cette dernière draft non
mais il ya un joueur ou cette année
je vois en fait ce qui est dit
jallet jurait que je vois voilà
je vois ce qu'il fait et ce qui est dit
sur ce joueur là même fils
et je vois ce que j'ai en tête ce que
j'ai vu à mon de vrd pendant une ou deux
saisons ici plus parce qu'il l'a
reclassé enfin bref et en fait je vois
pas du tout le même genre de com ad je
vois pas du tout le même voire
alors il ya la situation avec penny
hardaway qui
voilà on se ferait le nouveau khalife ou
peut-être on fera chacun fera son
opinion sur sur ce cet ancien joueur
formidable
mais pour l'instant coach à 6
voilà étonnant qu'ils utilisent de façon
assez assez étonnant et bila et je moi
je sais enfin j'ose et dont le syrien
vitaux mais je vois qu'il a pu faire des
choses qui ne fait plus qui pourra
refaire avec un staff nba qui va savoir
le faire travailler de la meilleure des
façons
c'est pour ça que moi je ne vois encore
très haut
et que je le verrai toujours très haut
je pense ouais ouais c'est intéressant
et il ya aussi un autre joueur dont on
va sans doute parler de ce point de vue
là cette année à la draft pour ceux qui
nous suivent déjà qu'ils sont allés voir
nos classements c'est patrick baldwin
junior puisque lui joue dans une toute
petite fac donc va avoir beaucoup de mal
mais il a joué avec team usa où il était
plus un joueur sur le spot 9 ce qu'on
lui demandera probablement en nba
on va parler de france chili qui n'a
quand même parce que à l'époque c'est le
joueur le mieux drafté le joueur
français le mieux drafté de l'histoire
quand il se fait drafté par les
knickerbockers ben
est ce que c'est un échec des knicks ou
est-ce que c'est dans un chèque de
francky lykina ou est ce que c'est un
échec des bleus je pense que c'est un
échec des deux
je pense que les knicks balises étaient
pas complètement est une franchise d
organiser jusqu'à ce que tom thibodeau à
riffles il y avait des
il y avait
des consignes contradictoires qui venait
à gauche à droite on faisait jouer
fringues comme cela soyez on le faisait
jouer on l'a soyez on le faisait jouer
post 3 ans la soie y est
pour lui juste un pauvre vraiment donné
sa chance non plus mais lorsqu'il était
sur le terrain
jeudi encore aujourd'hui jouent à peu
près pas à dallas
encore aujourd'hui il ne joue à peu près
pas à dallas contre les knicks la
semaine dernière a joué une minute price
pendant que du baryton mettait 32 dans
la tronche de le cas d'une chute spielen
le tenait à trois titres watts et
réussis sur 11 donc
je crois que je crois qu'il y aura moins
du monde en parlait dans le time you you
run est un chiffre un délit qui naquit
et de passer en premier
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya eu également
l'esprit offrir ce rapport
pour des organisations missions
d'attaqué quelquefois que ça influe je
crois me lisez coéquipiers de faveur
parce que
aucun soutien
on va faire un miroir un jeu de miroirs
ben est ce que tu te rappelles j'imagine
qu'est ce qui était attendu
de franck thil qui n'a quand il est
arrivé aux knicks c'est à dire que
disaient les fans quel genre de joueur
c'est et après roman va nous dire quel
joueur il était réellement à l'époque li
été drafté dans le fond pour jouer dans
le triangle de phil jackson pour être le
grand meneur qui initiait l'attaquent
triangle qui a jamais vraiment été
jamais vraiment été jouée par les knicks
était jouée à moitié à l'époque de jeff
hornacek après sa sphère jackson s'est
fait virer on s'attendait à ce qu'ils
soient capables de tirer
respectablement
justement incapable d'initier cette
série de mouvements le qu'ils allaient
monnerie pour vous ravir
c'est le libérer
je ne me rappelle même pas l'avoir vu
initiée l'attaqué en triangle
une fois face au parti ce parce que
beaucoup joué
moi je pense que le vin il y avait
énormément de deux familles mixtes
certain que je connais plutôt bien
ti surtout envie d'oublier cette période
de l'attaquant friands que je pense que
c'était peut-être
totalement improbable un peu baroque et
puis tiens pas apporté grand chose et
puis moi je pense aussi malheureusement
que que franck quelle que soit sa sa
potentialité ou autres en tout cas au
moment de la dramatique on dans un
contexte de franchise ou
ses avocats une tique c'est à dire que
avec fils dave on n'a jamais trop
compris ce qui se passait
il a jamais vraiment
oui il a eu du temps de jeu mais
toujours dans des contextes un peu
bizarre pour armand s'est exprimé
est-ce qui est ce qu en étant ailleurs
au départ à son arrivée en nba d'orient
standing différence c'est pareil c'est
difficile à dire parce que tu dis comme
que chez les knicks chili le draft il le
draff sur le spot où ils ont pris il ya
il a quand même une raison quelque part
et sur l'évaluation et sur plein de
choses qu'ils avaient montré il ya
peut-être des raisons des raisons d'y
croire d'espérer
je sais c'est très très dur à dire en
fait c'est très très dur à dire les
qualités adjoint ces questions ce qui je
pense qu'il les a
est ce que le fait son se rappelle à
l'époque il avait fait aucun mort coptes
parce qu'ils jouaient les finales avec
strasbourg est-ce que ça le fait de de
jouer longtemps sur la saison est-ce que
ça a pu jouer dans son drap stocks
est-ce que s'ils l'avaient fait par
exemple et walcott avec ce n'est pas
avec les migrants est ce qu'il aurait
été peut-être plus bas ou le fait de
jouer ça la selle lui a donné un peu
plus de
je patron ce qu'on a pas rappelés à un
jour un joueur
tu surévalué ce qu'on n'a pas tout
simplement surévalué la potentialité de
francs qui lui renvoie à ce qu'il est
devenu quatre ans je ne sais pas la
question pour moi les durs parce que si
tu prends au milieu d'eux au milieu de
la foule le jour avec le québec combien
de joueurs du top 15 ski qui sont qui
sont meneur meneur de jeu avec avec de
l'importance dans une équipe qui en haut
de tableau qui joue les playoffs de son
championnat domestique à l'âge qu'il
avait qui joue en coupe d'europe à l'âge
qu'il avait avec un avec un vrai rôle et
une importance
bien apparaître divisie pas que de jouer
des paresseuses caisse parce que c'est
mon club et je vois la bannière de sa
brave tous les jours au point mais ce
que je veux dire
o'neal est difficile voilà et puis file
comparé à des contextes mais à l'époque
franck à strasbourg
c'est un joueur c'est un joueur
important d'une équipe j'ai coaché par
le coach de l'équipe de france et qui
qui fait qui fait un vrai qui fait une
vraie saison alors oui oui perdre contre
chalon en finale c'est sûr mais je veux
dire quelque part par rapport au vécu et
à l'expérience qu'ont d'autres joueurs
qui sont drafté au dessus et en dessous
est-ce que c'est mieux est ce que c'est
moins bien en tout cas on a un joueur
qui joue face à des adultes et
l'histoire des draft récente prouve
quand même que malgré tout c'est quelque
chose qui tend à rassurer les
francophiles ces choses là
ce qui si on part comme ça il ya des les
européens comptent et leur a fait ces
dernières années qui avaient pas
forcément fait des bases work out non
plus mais qu étaient exposés pas sûr que
ou un prêt c'est un exemple extrême et
du canon cecina 50 d'être aidés des
work-outs pourtant il ya des gens qui
chantent passer devant lui sur la draft
les joueurs sont passés devant lui sur
la participation qu'ils aient une
empreinte sur la nba dans les années à
venir comme donc situera sur l'histoire
je suis à la période sur laquelle il va
jouer et pourtant on était tous les cas
d'accord ont été surpris qu'ils soient
premiers ok bon il est pas deuxième il
en est bizarre finale
je ne sais pas mais
c'est ces fonctions intéressantes et
samedan le chat nous dit de vous mettre
le message
technologie
vidéo
si le petit prince avait été drafté par
une autre franchise on parlerait pas de
lui comme étant un échec ben est ce que
tu es d'accord peut-être ça dépend la
franchise je crois que si l'arrêté
drafté par
n'importe quelle franchise qui avait pas
nécessairement la solution vise à
sacramento où il nicolas sa crème de
sacramento alias de marc petit patch
ce traiteur vous me détestez sur ça mais
il ya donc un cheese qu'il n'aurait pas
été capable de trouver une place non
plus parce que c'est un joueur qui avait
besoin djelic et d'un mot qui en a plus
il y en a eu aucunement oui si oui il
peut le défendre comme l'hymne meilleur
joueur nba mais ce droit étant le moins
sur le terrain quand même parce qu'ils
font n'y a absolument aucune attaque il
joue toujours en plus
de gens pensaient peut-être un peu
de l'histoire et visionner ce que je
fais mais
un contexte comme celui qui dit à de
diane denimal tonnes à memphis par
exemple lui aurait pas été bénéfique ou
même en suisse est-ce que je joue a
statistiquement c'est que donc en
2016-2017 donc il a
la même pas encore 19 ans de 18 ans à 18
ans sur des chiffres bruts 1 45 matches
joués en france sur le championnat à 45
matchs ce qui est déjà un volume
plutôt intéressant il ya 20 minutes 5
points avec avec nous on est des
chiffres quasiment 50% à 2 38% à 3
quand tu pour son intro en creusant un
peu moins de deux tirs par match c'est
pas énorme mais bon malgré tout il ya
quelque chose 60% ont lancé ce qui épate
ce qui n'est pas terrible mais derrière
par contre il a moins d'une balle perdue
sur son sur ces 20 minutes de temps de
jeu son ratio tuba beaucoup de passes
des 6000 à moins d'une balle perdue pour
un meneur de jeu 18 ans en première
division se trouve pas ça ridicule en b
c'est elle qui est certes à troisième
coupe d'europe mais malgré tout
championnat sur un basque est différent
du basket français
il est à 17 minutes ses stats augmente
il est à 7 points
40 quasiment 40% à 3 et son ratio passe
des six balles perdues il augmente
proportionnellement il ya deux îles à
2,25 pas perdu il ya le symbole perdu en
17 18 minutes c'était beaucoup les
malgré tout on est sur un joueur qui
serait saison on joue 59 matchs
quand on est capable de jouer 59 patch à
18 heures en ayant la rolls sur l'équipe
avec n'oublions pas c'était un vrai
joueur tout est dans le sens où
défensivement 10 coltiner des joueurs
des joueurs étrangers ainsi de suite
donc c'est à dire que on est quand même
sur un process d'évaluation
demande à olivier mazet l'occasion qui
nous en reparle c'était cd 102 c'était
son agent à l'époque un des principaux
artisans de sa marque
on est sur un jour pour moi sur le
papier et sur le fur le l'info brute
présente des garanties quand même par
rapport à d'autres je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez mais aujourd'hui si vous
parle d'un gamin sur l'approché
narrative qui a joué 59 pas de chant
d'europe à 20 minutes de moyenne sur une
coupe d'europe à champier les
domestiques on va tous se regardent en
disant c'est pas mal ouais mais moi j'ai
testé par météo
est
bonne il estimé est-ce qu'il était
forcément presque ippon mais forcément
nous dans le même contexte
c'est la question le regard de l'an
dernier pour théo le porter au bas des
dons et et mal malgré le contexte en
asie où il a fait quelques sorties
intéressantes les comptes et éthiques et
un
qui était qui est en perdition
cette vérité aussi le contexte encore
une fois enfin vous le dis tous les
zombies dans la raba chômage plus
difficile est super bon temps et pour
les profondes sur ce coup là pour dévier
d'un manchot fallois offrande sur ce
coup là le le le fit à voir c'est ce que
disent plusieurs personnes moutons
bailleur est ce que ça se passe
différemment j'irai prendre au milieu de
sa deuxième année il ya eu 7 cette
rumeur de potentiellement du trade avec
brooklyn qui avec avait traîné un petit
peu tu m'avais qu'il y ait une seule
messe que ça se passe différemment le
souci si tu peux pas écrire l'histoire
suivante sur un joueur comme ça ce qui
est dommage c'est qu'aujourd'hui ben
voilà c'est un joueur français on en
revient toujours français réussissent et
y est coincé il est coincé au bout de
rotation à à dallas même si en 14
minutes ce qui fait c'est pas des cônes
en mai mais loin de ce qu'on peu ce
qu'on peut attendre pour un pour un
huitième pour un huitième choix
de france il montrait même chose à
montrer des choses mais il n'a pas lé il
n'a pas le rôle qu'on attend du rôle
d'un huitième de draft et c'est là où je
voulais peut-être en vous amené manu ben
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ondraf d'un joueur
dont la principale un arrière pardon
dont la principale force et défensives
dans le top 10
bah si on croit en son staff et on
travaille qui peut fournir
moi c'est un risque que je prends au
lapin c'est un
comparatif extrême mais kawai ils
savaient pas shooter est arrivé aux
spurs avec hawaii s'est pas en arrière
sans nier qu'ils
n'ont springs est ce que les spurs le
prenne en pensant qu'ils pourraient un
franchise player comme il l'a été on
sait pas longtemps finalement on ne
tourne que trois ans pas ils ont fait un
taf immense avec lui in ans et je pense
que pas beaucoup de personnes pensaient
qu'ils allaient pouvoir se développer
autant ouais mais tu reviens sur le
prime de départ là tu pars d'une
franchise qui c'est la rareté
mais j'ai pas actionner que sa part a
fait c'est pas du tout le propos mais il
dit juste qu'elle et moi vous dire qu'on
dit new york new york de l'extérieur
c'est c'est un bordel sa mort des
institutionnels et institutionnalisée
c'est pas trop ça va c'est fou et cetera
et cetera le meti draft qui l'a rappelé
franck à lille quasiment pas là à
l'arrivée c'est pas évident san antonio
c'est l'effet inverse ça fait 30 ans que
ça bouge pas et en attendant moi je sais
que j'en parlais cet après midi au
regard des différents joueurs lloret mes
collègues quand tu crois que des mecs
sont passés par certaines franchises ne
serait ce que par le système de j league
ça donne sur certains déjà des garanties
un petit peu sur la sur la tige sur la
tête des gens les joueurs passés par les
parrains par l'équipe de geely des spurs
j'en ai j'en ai eu ou croiser certains
cas quand même rarement d
des abrutis abattis arrive en europe
très souvent c'est comme des mecs
où ils capacité à se connaître qui fait
qu'ils peuvent être efficaces ou des
joueurs intelligents ce boulet ou les
deux mais voilà il ya des équipes en
revanche
c'est comme les facs des facs ou du sol
de certaines fois que tu sais ce que
d'agents bien souvent sur l'exemple de
sur les ordres de belles heures mais
l'or depuis depuis depuis sept huit ans
lemay qui sort de vélo tu sais ce que tu
en termes d'état d'esprit vous savez
j'ai les joueurs de memphis autres
l'asse c'est déjà plus à la voir ben
yahya un
cheat storm sur le stade développement
des knicks dans le tchat
je devrai l'agent de la moitié mais
est-ce que sur les dix dernières années
il ya provenir de rookie qui ont faim de
joueur drafté par les knicks qui ont
réussi aux knicks depuis
2008 m robinson djebar est
emmanuelle coint européen de musique y
en a beaucoup vu
depuis 2008
depuis 2002 puis intégral mais
prohibe vraiment
vraiment hamas et toutes arrivées avec l
administration de la drogue vers
l'irlande et césar fut tout aussi puis
c'est
un bon feeling good bye à un pommier
chose c'est que c'est que franck sa
dernière année où s'en va voir dernières
années je sais plus quand il y est il
lui faut une palanquée de meneur de jeu
ou d'arrière dans les jambes l'équipe à
l'ailé avec avec fidel c'est sans queue
ni tête à la transe y retrouver tous t3
alors j'étais un mec sur sur un poste
arrière c'est c'était complètement
illisibles donc dans quelle mesure à ce
qu'ils ont fait ça parce que j'ai pas de
garantie woods qui a encore une fois on
n'est pas en internement c'est rien ici
jusque le joueur a sa part de
responsabilité sûrement y compris sur
monsieur sur des intel qu'on peut avoir
ou autre mais derrière le contexte le
contexte est
pas parce que moi cette rafle a ça m'a
surtout appris à ne pas projeter sur des
choses que les joueurs n'ont pas ça
c'est facile à zéro heure il ya juste
besoin d'avoir un tir à trois points ça
va être génial mais si le gars il ya des
40 % aux lancers francs puis c'est
surtout projeté manu sur ce soit
intéressant tu donner l'exemple de kauai
leonard kaw leonard avait créé mauvais
pourcentage au tir mais comme elle ne
l'avait pas grand-chose à modifier il
mettait son ballon je suis si par dessus
ça va être juste que tu es peinture n a
fait il l'a juste souliers joue sur un
petit ballon il est compact et ça ce
sont sa motion t et
c'était projetable de ce que ce que ce
que khawaja n'ont été capables de voir
quelqu'un comme farinelli kiener ou
comme on l'apprendra tantôt josh jackson
mot
souhaitait on souhaitait quelque chose
on souhaitait un le coup de baguette
magique
un joueur justement qui a eu besoin de
six mètres de se mettre les pieds du lit
plus loin dans la vase jusqu'aux coudes
pour travailler et qui ne l'ont pas
encore fait jouer cinq militants à 30
quelques pour ça
et josh jackson chi jeu j'ai pas les
yeux quand joe jackson voisins mais
alors les récents parce que l'on parle
souvent ben il était bien placé pour le
savoir parce que je te thann pour tutu
tu commences tu es scouting report par
sa part lan l'analyse du du joueur
psychologique
est ce que le fait justement ce que manu
disais tout à l'heure il n'y a pas eu de
processus pré draft ou très peu pour
fronty lykina
est-ce que pour vous on a on a tout
simplement mal évalué
son mental sa capacité de travail sa
capacité à rester sérieux
sincèrement enfin encore une fois je ne
vais pas
j'ai même agent qu'il avait à l'époque
on en a parlé plein de fois et
qu'olivier sens qu'il sent qu'ils me
donnent les secrets du truc et compagnie
mais il m'a expliqué que en termes
d'évaluation il est élu et comme
n'importe quel autre joueur la seule
différence plutôt d'y aller ils sont
venus tôt mais le process le process
draft il a eu la seule différence et qui
sait pas cogner des work-outs pour aller
tirer faire des tirs en cours sur un
compteur des trucs servent à rien comme
ils font une certaine franchise mais
au-delà de ça son process d'évaluation
et ça je vais pas parler de passe de
lier mais son process d'évaluation
d'innover il a été complet je pense en
parle quand j'en parle encore mme avec
avec mon collègue aujourd'hui qui cause
principale à strasbourg à l'époque ils
ont ils disent qu'ils ont du disque où
défilent et aurelius ou sur les salles à
l'extérieur vous imaginez bien campus
avec quand un entraîneur principal qui
est coach de l'équipe de france le mec
il est facilement accessible pour les
franchisés compagnie française de draft
et d'évaluation bie compris
psychologique qu'il a fait comme les
autres encore une fois
faire draft et c'est gagné au loto sauf
que la franchise elle va décider s'il te
fait gagner ou pas au loto et la
franchise mise à part avant certains
sympa car on sait que c'est pourri mais
qui vont pas prendre de risque qui a
gagné 3 4 5 6 suivirent et oubliez pas
un truc c'est qu'ils ont de l'option
qu'ils ont prolongé quand même sur son
contrat rookie donc c'est qu'à un moment
oui et sûrement quelque chose qui s'est
pas cap' appliquées correctement mais
malgré tout on est au bout de leur
démarche aussi même si le player des va
pas forcément été excellents par rapport
à lui on n'est pas là pour juger on à
l'extérieur mais quelque part les choses
ont été faites et la franchise je pense
qu'elle est tenue le late midi jusqu'au
bout après ça traîne ça traîne ça reste
un business aussi et compagnie mais
alors elle précisément quand même ils
ont enlevé lé timochenko ne pas
prolonger c'est à dire non et enlever
les temps est ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'ils ont enlevé les cimes auctions à
des moments où il n'était pas obligé de
faire en plus
mais je vais dire ils l'ont fait qu'ils
ont perdu gratuitement
gratuitement mais d'un autre côté et de
l'autre côté encore une fois et c'est
quelque chose que katie souvent
n'oubliez pas qu'on a l'expérience on
voit pas on sait pas ce qui se passe
sur le terrain pour un marché
dont il a été fait cet effet plusieurs
fois et la dernière fois que cet effet
notamment c'était sur une rumeur de
traîne qui a vu avec détroit et c'était
c'était je crois
la carrière j'en avais entendu parler il
y avait déjà vu quelque chose comme ça
il ya eu une rumeur de trad avec détroit
mais ils ont essayé ils ont essayé avant
avec la une plusieurs fois gg plus
l'année en tête il serait trop passait
plus mais ils ont essayé de le proposer
sur marché le problème c'est encore une
fois la valeur du joueur fait que si pas
parce que tu en fasses si tu veux tu
fais pas donc voila mais on à
l'extérieur on n'a pas tout les ans il
ya il ya aussi le côté pression n'est
pas le même qu'en france ça c'est
certain sam dans le chat nous nous en
parlait tout à l'heure et j'en discutais
tout à l'heure avec pascal gilles
berniquez et journaliste français
spécialisé basket basée à new york a
donc suivi toute la saga quand franck
est arrivé et c'est malheureusement peut
pas être avec nous ce soir mais on ne
salue et on en discutait tout à l'heure
par message disait jamais eu un buzz
comme ça en français en nba jamais
jamais jamais à son arrivée en nba c'est
à dire que le fait que ça soit new york
le fait qu'ils soient choisis le
français le plus haut de l'histoire le
fait que ben voilà il avait déjà une
expérience en pro dont qu'il était censé
apporter vite fort pour une équipe des
knicks qui était en besoins de
reconstruction etc tout ça a mis
beaucoup de pression sur les épaules de
tig qui
les lie fiennes ne sont pas venus
toujours un oeil désespéré atos avoir
une une un montage vidéo hommage à rené
sur cet aspect pour moi enfin si on
regarde c'est un peu ce terreau youri
pour moi ça dérape dans ce sens là il ya
réfléchi parce que quelque part tous que
ça crée comme attentes de dell soit
rachetée au le buzz experts externes a
fait cas draft été réussi y compris dans
la gestion qu'on a eu la franchise mais
également la laddh le jour le jour après
est ce que est ce que est ce qu'il a été
réussie on va dire sur le plan sur
l'emballage après des risques dans ces
autres choses mais mais en tout cas si
l'évaluation n'avait pas été correct
avant la draft il aurait pu vu ça comme
résultat un siess buzz là et compagnie
c'est parce qu'il ya des choses qui sont
dites des choses sont sorties conduite
et galas et loire après jour pareil live
richard l'admirent c'est ça il faut
réussir à la tenir il ya aussi le le
côté alors moi je dis ça et je vais pas
citer mes sources parce que c'est pas
mon boulot ici mais mais on sait que new
york ville de tentations et on sait qu
on sait que francky là il a parfois
succombé à ces tentations sens sans
jeter la pierre à personne dans une tout
ce dont je ne jette pas la pierre pierre
1 c'est un grand garçon il fait ce qu'il
veut mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
peut-être que donovan mitchell serait
moins sorti que franck tilly qui
n'annule
ses deux res et il ma nouvelle recrue
clay en 2020 c'est vraiment petit garçon
catalytique face aprilia équipements
mobiles
moi je pense que même si jean-luc ce
genre là tu sais tu échappes new york in
trois mois ça ça peut vite ça peut vite
se compliquer oui et oui là la
grosse pomme empoisonnée pour pour
franck ribéry n'a alors
joe jackson ben
jackson je ne peux pas mais on ne tue va
nous présenter ton autre erreur
d'évaluation plus tard mais c'est plus
pour les pauvres pour les pour les gens
pointu pour les spécialistes mais la joe
jackson quatrième choisi par les 200
l'énergie edison
copie stone aujourd'hui et je choisis
par les suns
dis nous ce que tu en attendaient ce
qu'il est devenu et pour toi les raisons
de les raisons de l'échec bang comme je
vous en ai parlé tout à l'heure je
souhaitais quelque chose que quelques
choses apparaissent par magie dans
l'arsenal de joe jackson joue et qui
n'avait pas au
à 15 ans mais vraiment pas du tout et
c'est un athlète absolument incroyable
un défenseur extrêmement rapide athlète
switch qui était capable de de switcher
réchauffe plusieurs postes sont offerts
à chaque fois il y avait beaucoup de
problèmes avec les mandarins peu plus a
dit là les riches de ce monde
il te pose non plus le plus le le monde
paraît sûre je te dirai que je dirais
que je n'ai vu abandonner souvent très
rapidement sur plusieurs jours et
contenant des mots avec un profil comme
ça c'était lié
cet ailier polyvalent capable de jouer
des deux côtés du terrain
moi ça a été un choc du désastre complet
à une vie y est il est à peu près sorti
d'allier qui jouaient des trois
aujourd'hui me brasser par mille fils et
je crois qu'il est passé à quelques
bordeaux si je veux vérifier mais il
était arrêté plusieurs fois
d'un ideye fait même fils et phoenix
memphis
detroit il y avait un peu de j league ou
si ils étaient tous et derrière phoenix
même fusée 3 samedi pour la descente aux
enfers quand même là où la route de
houlle à
la brosse et la route 66 a long way ccsa
c'est la route 666 là pour ce que tu
penses tu pas tu passes de 50 degrés
avec la rente à -12 c'est compliqué
fait s'arrêter avec l'apple plusieurs
fois
c'est quelqu'un saint jouin qui n'a pas
été fait que celui qui n'a pas été
arrêté avec de la dinde
nommé là puisqu'il galicie
c'est un joueur qui quitte et
psychologiquement parlant
c'est difficile de comprendre pour
certains joueurs qu'une fois dans
l'avenir on recommence il faut qu'on
retrouve toujours les tous les joueurs
travaillent tellement toute leurs vie
pour se rendre à albi pour certains
d'entre eux lorsqu'ils sont rendus lits
sont rendus ces îles sont au paradis
laura dieu ils sortent ou tous les soirs
ils profitent de leur âge ils en donnent
absolument finir d3d content pas
exactement exactement ce qui s'est passé
avec josh jackson qui là ils essaient de
sauver ce qui reste de la carrière mais
les réflexes on voit là il prend
n'importe qui tirent il ya eu de la
difficulté à comprendre dans quel
contexte va être efficace dans quel
contexte d'utiliser moi j'aime vraiment
j'ai vraiment peu
il ya eu deux problèmes qui font en
sorte que puis un problème technique
c'est vrai qu'elle va pâtir d'un
problème psychologique justement fait
que pour lui ait rendu nba c'était assez
urgent social vous bois exactement
exactement c'est surtout une personne
s'appelant des blogs selon moi on fait
en sorte que joe jackson a été et est un
poste en bois du type oui la coupe est
pleine pour josh mais choisit quatrième
pas pour rien manu je sais pas comment
tu l'évaluent à l'époque mais aussi au 4
mai c'était extraordinaire
je me rappelle que manu battu à rennes
j'ai beaucoup lorsque je faisais mais
mais mais mais mais huit meetings joe
jackson il avait
après j'aime est pas mal moins après ski
ce qui me fait en peluche et sur lui
c'est qu'il ait croisé la route des
bills seule fois
mais peut-être peut-être ce qui les
guettait les gros sac de sport bien
chargé non c'est pas
interdit dans le coffre de la twingo ils
étaient des gros sacs de sport bien
chargé
et on
sait par le expérience si je puis dire
que à chaque fois que bill self a eu un
freshman cinq toiles ou top freshman ça
s'est pas bien passé c'est pareil avec
wiggins
higgins il a pas réussi à le développer
pour des requins du ca si je vois là
sans regarder mais au regard des kansas
pour wiggins et on finissait par voir le
jour et les bilans fait mais joey limite
n'est pas
si je n'en ai pas attendu pour être une
star en arrivant à kansas
et finalement il devient un monstre
mais bref jeux pour mobiles de phil
jackson qu'est ce que je raconte will
self admis par un point à jouer là
dedans ou qui je trouve qu'ils cassent
un peu tu peux casser des carrières
je m'en viens d'être chauvin de l'acier
c'est la seule ligue au monde encore
aujourd'hui qui est le mythe de coach
ouais des coachs blanc d'ailleurs en
plus
et je moi je vais en voudrait toujours
pour un joueur s'équilibrer
où il arrivait on top très show man
encore une fois exceptionnelle en high
school il arriva en place ils jouent pas
deux minutes par match noah
et pour moi en fait je sais pas ce qui
leur fait mais il doit le rencontrer
dans la tête ou ou quelque chose
un jour perry ellis qui avait 55 ans à
l'époque mais un
après un prêt de revenir sur joe jackson
il ya aussi un paramètre les joueurs
californiens c'est toujours quelque
chose de très très particulier à gérer
à oui enfin moi je vois qu'il est né à
san diego donc
il a fait il a fait la preuve school il
a fait preuve school prep school dans le
il a fait preuve school dans le michigan
mais derrière c'était politiques
prennent pour les fibres mcc californie
et lui laissant diego et des california
j'en ai croisé quelques-uns dans ma
carrière mon à cette année là qui soit
le san diego state et qui est qu
avancent très bien
mais très souvent c'est
inconsciemment c'est
céline bak au niveau attitude contre et
que c'était les joueurs de géorgie ce
non non ça sent que c'est en conséquence
encore au dessus tu me rappelles
quelques quelques souvenirs de pro b
mais là les joueurs les joueurs du les
californiens sont ici très très souvent
comme ça
oui
regardez
bien de frêche l'a déjà juste peu manu
sur bill self
pour regarder la la n6 est
régulièrement même si comme ça ce n'est
pas mon programme préféré en terme de
jeu c'est quand même on est loin du
kentucky kelly paris dont on parlait
tout à l'heure c'est la wii non il ya le
haut niveau je cite à tourner on a pris
cette décision c'est un temps avec des
juniors seniors là aussi c'est aussi
insupportable mais
effectivement on regardait jouer comme
ça c'est sûr mais on est bien d'accord
sa seule moins artificiel il ya autant
de je pense qu'il ya autant de autant de
sacs emplis d'un coffre mais c'est
s'avère moins artificiel cadets joe
jackson c'est un sac de peu
après après de jackson si tu regardes ça
veut dire saison quasiment c'est sa
saison rookie
parce qu'il a vu six heures parce qu'il
est en jeu après derrière moi je vois
qu'aujourd'hui la vague à moins de 30% à
3 vont aujourd'hui des flingues et dans
tous les sens qu'ils ont ça ça me fait
mal de le dire ce que mon jeu est
toujours j'ai toujours cette relique pas
très loin de moins mais les débits des
équipes c'est bill mais les types d
pistone cl à la dérive depuis tellement
longtemps à biars
6,84
ouais mais mais oui pour finir là-dessus
quand j'ai fait mes recherches parce que
je vous parlais des contrats tout à
l'heure pour essayer d'évaluer la
réussite d'un joueur bon à
209 millions quand même de rien s'est
passé c'est pas si rien c'est mieux
petit latina dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est mieux que
j'affectionne et c'est joe jackson il a
quand même fait une pe l'utiliser parce
que trop regardé 5 millions deuxième 6
3e set 4e 8 et là il est revenu à 5
millions sont là quand même mis un peu
de un peu d'argent sur livret bleu sur
le pel et puis la ldd doit être remplie
aussi
c'est ça n'incite pas à se mettre au
boulot sophie lâcher la roue alors
autant en bagnole et qui d'acheter les
billets par les
mets mais ce que je voulais dire c'est
que le site où je regardais les
transactions là
pour une raison que j'ignore ils
recensaient les fautes techniques il a
énormément de fautes techniques non
c'est dans sa saison rookie et sur fond
d'or j'ai rarement vu alors la dent sur
les photos tirées pendant la comparaison
du genre écrit mohamed rasheed wallace
quelque chose comme ça
sorte de rasheed wallace du pauvre
c'est ça mais effectivement c'était un
bon joueur à kansas en tout cas bon un
bon joueur qui shootait à 56 % aux
lancers francs manqués des indices mais
il y avait des filles à hambourg un jeu
il avait une je crois que jean bouise
match quelque chose comme ça tout ça
c'est vraiment ce qui suit à 50% à 3
points l'ag avec complètement persuadé
qui voyez mais c'est sur la les moments
de conférence en marge de conférences
il avait très chaud
ça c'est ça mais en tout cas donc joe
jackson un bel échec
d'ailleurs c'est un échec assis plus
dire cuisant sachant qu'il passait par
phoenix et memphis qui à l'heure
actuelle ont réussi à sortir des joueurs
de maradona lui s'en sorti du marasme en
ressentir des joueurs parce que c'est
comme un phénix et l'anglais dans les
deux cas c'est vrai même si ça allait
mais
ces dernières années c'est très bien
ça n'arrive à même tisse avec 10 anthony
melton qui pour le coup ils ont gardé
comme par hasard qu'un très bon jouer un
super g3 40 millions $ pour
les non dits intelligents 61 que
j'aimais et qui m'a donné raison
c'est un c'était un
favori des des amoureux de stade avancé
mais beaucoup
mais ils produisaient beaucoup
d'événements défensif commandes comme on
dit qu il ya des réflexes de spider man
2 dans les lignes de passes j'ai jamais
vu un joueur avec une anticipation
de nouvelles mitchell messieurs c'est le
prochain thème parce que donovan
mitchell pour le coup je crois qu'on est
à peu près tous
passés à côté en tout cas il n'avait
aucun qu'il avait dans le top 10
alors thuan bérenger antoine déranger la
vie comme dans lequel comptait avait dit
selon lê huu
selon les échos que j'ai eus de laval
mitchels outre est beaucoup mieux que ce
qu'il a montré que cette saison un point
de charlotte à douala v cole et
l'algérie tous deux en plus tant le
light la graph juste pour voir qu'est ce
qu'on en est
et dans de nouvelles michel ben qu'est
ce qu'on a raté
tout seul oui bill qu'est ce qu'on a
raté le shoot le le le talent à la mène
le talent avec le ballon de créateurs
pour lui de créer à boire pour les
autres somme athlétisme
qu'est ce qu'ils étaient capables de
faire lorsque des schémas était dessiné
pour lui
je crois que c'est beaucoup amélioré
lorsqu'il arriverait agriculteurs parce
qu'ils vont nous parce que c'est un
joueur très haut qi basket ils ont mis
dans des stations de films c'est nous on
note jerry bryant maintenant new york
qui était le coach qui a été une quiche
ados dans nos matières premières qui ont
des moyens disait j y étais dans le
chaque jour avec moi donc stop stop stop
stop stop goûte peu viril beau truc ça
l'excitait les lire et les moyens de
donner
puis quand jouera t on a tendance à dire
une fois qu'un joueur et sa forme en
juniors-seniors la courbe de progression
s'aplatit mais quand le joueur a une
intelligence de jour où tu n'as moyenne
un désert au dessus de la moyenne des
les capacités athlétiques de suite
le ciel est la limite le shit on dans
une bonne situation il est tombé à utah
qui sont au moins est une des idées des
trois équipes les bleues oh coach est
l'ennemi
mérite comme jamais depuis deux ans je
crois que justement ça a été un euro le
mariage
propos qu'il aurait qui leur évite en
soirée
manu est ce qu'il ya une leçon à retenir
que tu as retenu par la suite où on va
retenir
bientôt sur sur l'évaluation on a pu
faire dodo
ben pouvez vous cacher c'est pas un
joueur qui m'avait marqué moi plus que
ça à louisville à l'époque mais j'avais
il ya un truc qui me revient en tête à
ce qu'on parle de lui c'est effet sortie
d'une terre bouge puis ça après la draft
ou ou pendant le processus toucher plus
quoi où ils disaient les gens n'ont pas
vu ce que je pouvais être ce que je
pouvais faire parce qu'en fait c'est
très difficile d'allier le les cours et
le basket en gros il y dit et maintenant
que je suis 100% baskets et bats je peux
montrer toutes mes capacités tout ce que
je sais faire en fait et travailler
beaucoup plus facilement que je pouvais
le faire à louisville où il devait
enchaîner moi y avait des raisons d'état
dragon évidemment mais un mémo moins
poussés parce qu'il devait réviser parce
qu'ils veulent en course il y aller on
ne sait pas on n'est pas à l'intérieur
encore une fois mais ça ça va amener ça
m'avait tilter parce que je trouve que
ça montre un peu là intelligente du
dugas aussi dit je sais pourquoi entre
guillemets je suis drafté assez de place
là
et pourquoi j'arrive à il comprend
comment travailler en tron c'est comme
ça je le vois chez lui
je pense que s'il m'avait regardé les
chiffres
je pense que le tout était là je viens
de regarder ses photos marie un volume
de tirs à trois points assez hallucinant
toujours bon signe un souvent et ils
shootent à 35% dégueulasse
et ils shootent à 80 aux lancers des
stades de tir étaient là par contre pour
moi ce qu'on aurait pu allier en fait
c'est de regarder ses stats de tir et
devoirs il était athlétique parce que
par contre ça sur les ça ne se voyait
pas ici c'est mal auxerre
il avait du mal à finir au cercle et il
provoque est assez peu de fautes quand
il avait il avait plutôt le ballon entre
les mains
même s'il devait le partager avec notre
notre arrière pas mal de visage à
l'époque j'étais
ben est ce que est ce que la leçon
aujourd'hui avec avec donovan mitchell
s'est pas
justement peut-être regarder un petit
peu plus le volume quand on regarde les
tirs le volume de tirs pris la confiance
à prendre un tir en fait
ben oui et non je dis est faux pas on
peut pas emmener ses amants on peut pas
nécessairement se fier à seul parce que
des foyers des raisons pour lesquelles
du joueur
certains problèmes de
confiance
alors joie mais mais c'est sûr que
fonctionne mettre la puce à l'oreille ce
qu'il faut que ça met la puce à
l'oreille surtout si jouons nous
intéresse dans un contexte de draft 6
thomas leveaux le métro à paris
m
désolé
nous avons des plans d'effets sonores
salut salut tes collègues
romain je sais pas si c'est à des
souvenirs du donovan mitchell de
l'époque mais c'est un joueur qui
progresse de saison en saison en tout
cas on y est vraiment chaque année ils
ajoutent des nouvelles couches à son jeu
des nouvelles nuances plus tôt
comment comment on peut prévoir un
joueur comme ça est ce que c'est de la
pure évaluation psychologique de savoir
qu'un joueur finalement va va être
capable d'ingurgiter d'ingurgiter
d'ingurgiter a aidé de ressortir avec
efficacité sur inter
notablement tas comme des finales en
cours après moi j'attends désormais son
genre est ce qu'on trouve sous les yeux
gg je peux vous dire de connerie j'ai
pas j'ai pas forcément trop de souvenirs
de l'époque universitaire le concernant
ce qui est mal ce
n'était pas en fin moi j'ai jamais
beaucoup aimé
[Musique]
voilà c'est ça c'est pas le gg j'ai pas
trop de souvenirs ce que j' avoue
modestement louis l'insep à la fin que
je regardais plus
c'est voir après
il ya toujours un il ya toujours un
terrain un terrain propice au
développement vous le fait qu'il ait
doublé au niveau stats quasiment sur ses
deux premières années
une indication après moi j'ai tendance à
dire que même sur la dimension
dit à la détermination à la capacité du
joueur à du joueur a vraiment passé un
cap
son lacement la peau départ c'est à dire
que deux joueurs équivalent je suis aux
caïmans quelque chose il tapera le
plafond tôt ou tard hélas mitchell et
d'arrivants nba
matière un petit peu fracassante il a
surtout la chance de tomber dans un
contexte encore une fois des tic ou
tous des rôles tous les rôles c'est dire
que
quick snyder prend les commandes il ya
quelque chose autour qui se met en place
correctement aujourd'hui mais qu'il est
joueur il est incontournable
l'incontournable pourquoi parce que je
pense pas qu'on arrive à ces niveaux-là
sens
sans travail parce que l'on louiseville
s'assume pas correct mais c'est pas
forcément pas forcément l'exposition
autorise à kentucky ou sur d'autres sur
d'autres programmes déjà les aimer avec
la ligne tertiaire
il aime bien les sacs de sport aussi oui
oui il ya bien les sacs de sport aussi
les sacs de sport guy les demoiselles
quand paye il a commencé c'est la
méthode six à huit hommes pitino ça mais
sur ce profil de joueur malgré tout
paris tu arrives au jazz qui est il
équipé la franchise dans la
reconstruction il ya quelques jours
autour pour un des luttes supporting
cast etc etc et au final un vrai coach
et tout se met en place donc je pense
que encore une fois on nous parlait de
franck tout à l'heure c'est le débarquer
à new york ou warhol en dos
oui mais l' inverse c'est pas oui mais
l' inverse
franck civique in as qu'il est à ta
carrière de nomades michels il est
drafté par résultats mais là on n'est
pas sur le danger venait pas on n'est
pas sur la prochaine et par là là tu
l'as tu parles là tu es déjà tu étais
plus tu étais sur un tissu en arrière à
à vocation légèrement sur le scoring et
qui tombe dans une franchise ou très
vite
parce qu'il force peut-être le destin
aussi mais parce que le contexte qui
permet de faire il récupère les clés du
camion et non seulement les qpr les clés
du camion et en plus il le fait bien
open bar
corrigez moi c'est les autres mais je
crois que gordon & wine est parti cet
été là aussi à boston ouais non c'est ça
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que tout ce
qu'elle vient et bien derrière si tu
regardes sont d'évolution statistiques
grâce
c'est sans science base uniquement sur
les chiffres parce qu'on sait aussi
c'est un joueur capable de jeu des deux
côtés du terrain mais 21 24 25 27 / sur
l'évolution de ses linéaires dire que ça
veut dire que le mec malgré tout encore
aujourd'hui si on s'engage à trois
points il est passé de 33 à quasiment 40
aujourd'hui dont ce qui fait en termes
de progression quel âge ils 26 donc il
est il arrive à son prime bientôt le
joueur il est comme ça depuis tillier
c'est par hasard ce le joueur les
prédispositions inévitablement mais
queen sneijder est quand même connu pour
être d'une part à cause passer par les
initiés donc qui sait faire ces choses
là il s'est développé et d'autre part
c'est comme quelqu'un de référencer et
qui a plus rien à prouver sur la
capacité à faire passer des caps aux
joueurs au niveau vert pour en parler
aussi des par exemple comme d'autres
joueurs passés par le jazz récemment que
le contexte pour lui il est il est bon
mais parce qu intrinsèquement au départ
c'est une bonne c'est un bon choix bras
et que le mec qui est bon
et ce qu'on sous-estimé
sous-estiment les sophomores trop
d'effort des sophomores généralement
surtout avec les différentes classes de
haut niveau de la draft
moi je pense qu'on peut les sous-estimer
autant que certains veulent aller trop
vite seize cesser ses ambivalences c'est
à dire que ta ta ta des joueurs où ne va
pas vouloir on va pas vouloir en tenir
compte parce que ce sera sophomore
parfois même junior dans certains cas
alors qu'il ya des vrais joueurs de
basket a récupéré et d'un autre côté des
joueurs qui vont qui vont se gaufrer
parce qu'ils veulent absolument y aller
sur l'année très chaud même pour des
raisons pour des raisons économiques et
politiques auront même social qu'on peut
comprendre
mais quelque part
d'aider des sophomores des travaux il
peut y avoir
beaucoup exemple à erize halliburton
iowa state
jamais
pardon jamais rentrer jamal
qui sol qui sort en plus qui sont en
plus de me restait qu'une fan
d'importance - là encore par rapport à
même par rapport à luisi dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure je me reste espoirs ont
parlé pour jj voire trois joueurs qui en
fait là bas si c'est pas les serveurs
grosse faim mais
voilà c'est parfois un an plus tard non
plus oui dans certains cas non plus ça
peut faire perdre dix spots mais tu as
des joueurs qui en un an ont réussi à
capitaliser draft qu'aujourd'hui on peut
reprendre les discussions qu'on avait
sur jam arendt à l'époque je pense pas
que ou temps qu'on soit on peut projeter
comme ça
oui vous l'avez tout ce grabuge à dire
sur le contenu je suis rendu qu'on a
aujourd'hui un instant t où les leaders
d'une équipe qui est en pleine bourre a
tendance à dans sa conférence je pense
pas qu'on soit capable de voir ça y est
rond
[Musique]
deuxième tournoi premier tour il pose un
triple double et deuxième tour ils se
font sortir
mais parce que parce que voilà on a
vraiment d'autres classiques de la dalle
de la halle de la petite fac en fait à
à me restait donc casque a fourni
beaucoup de joueurs pour l'europe mais
mais quelque part ça cesse pour moi ça
illustre énormément de parcours et la
qualité du joueur tim et arriva à
transférer ce qu'ils étaient capables de
faire à la fac au niveau nba en sachant
qu'ils sauront une petite institution
qui travaillent traduiront de blanc ça
remonte le gap qui avait avoir franchi
avec ce qu'est ce que le joueur a réussi
à bien ces c'est non
cette année ben yahia
et un sophomore qui est en train de
monter tout changer dans l'étrave board
de manière
exponentielle peut-être trop
s'appelle johnny davis john hayes
flannery swisscom sin oui on en a parlé
récemment
tu aime beaucoup est ce que tu penses
que peut avoir un destin similaire
je pense que c'est un gros fardeau à lui
mettre sur les impôts présentement la
mais c'est un
scoreur naturel je trouve c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment naturel est
intéressant aussi qui capable de changer
la géométrie du jeu tant par son tir
pourtant pas
la comparaison et pau est à côté de la
plaque mais peu de soul
le de thomas a raison dans le chat il
nous dit de jay de naïli peine à turin
se gagnera les juniors mais
effectivement les peurs classemen monde
y sont sont peuvent être assez nombreux
dans aller la loterie peut-être
entier alors c'est ce qu on en revient à
la discussion qu'on avait la dernière
fois romain on disait
la génération qu'ovide high school
qu'ovide et peut-être aussi moins - mise
en valeur du fait du manque de
développement sur sur les derniers mots
avoir
moi il peut il peut y avoir il peut y
avoir un petit un petit creux
générationnel éventuellement cc c'est
possible là je regarde les stats de
davis là là il a quasiment doublé la
seule chose par contre c'est que son
pourcentage à 3 points s'est effondrée
avec la responsabilité ce qui soulève
quand même quelques questions notamment
sur la sélection tient il passe de
quasiment 40 à 27 bon sur un volume qui
était pas qu'ils n'étaient pas énormes
et normand dernier mais c'est ça reste
quand même quelque chose qu'il peut et
il peut soulever des questions mais pour
revenir à ce que tu sais que tu disais
oui il y aura duré inévitablement un
creux un creux générationnel et un
moment après l'ampleur lampes et or je
ne sais pas on aura déjà un élément de
réponse cet été que les championnats les
championnats et compétitions
internationales et jeunes qu'il ya du
monde u-17 et à tous les championnats
d'europe arrêtons de voir un peu les les
joueurs en compétition et ce sera les
premières générations joueurs qu'on
passait sa part un an un an et demi sans
son vraie opposition ou du moins sur des
choses restreinte avec moins de matches
et c'est par ex et
oma tu as raison dans le chat qui
gagnent murray sophomore c'est juste
qu'il a l'âge d'un junior
c'est un vieux vieux sophomore du côté
de wigan
[Musique]
marc hé
ben le titre wild card pour finir sur
cette
tranquillement sortir sur cette draft
2010 est un joueur sur lequel tu t'es
trompé qui était un peu moins connus
comme youtube qui joue à taïwan
aujourd'hui italien qui a joué à
washington et qui a joué dans l'argile
et
j'étais convaincu que ce joueur est là
et le pic de problème je l'avais
je ne voyais comme étant un futur tube
if enfin jouer je le croyais d'arts
martiaux juniors 1 elie junior
[Musique]
6,8 je veux sans lui
qui est un
des principaux freins il n'est pas à
100%
pendant ces trois années que ça ne crut
personnes
drafté
[Musique]
washington risque était le problème
n'était pas aussi rapide que
lui est plus facile à contourner malgré
qu'il est long mais tout se poser on est
vraiment peau on est jugé sur les joies
qui ont réagi et qui ont qui ont réussi
à très haut niveau on n'est pas jugé sur
les joueurs qu'on espérait mais ça c'est
un autre je pense en 2016 dénommé travel
par un terrain aussi que jouer à
marylène que je voyais vraiment très
audacieux j'essaie vraiment de beaux
gros ratés chez moi mais robinson
j'avais complètement vie qu'il existait
jusqu'à cet après midi
est ce que tu en tire des leçons bien
ouais
je crois que je crois que justement sur
joueurs n'arrivent pas à s'imposer en
tant que junior comme
l'équipe se poser des questions la
question du podium aussi pour les
territoires pour les témoins
étaient vraiment prévu
comme ça
mais il vient jouer en clinique jusqu'à
cette année
le jour de mon 39e anniversaire pour la
taille - je crois pas qu'on va l'avoir
une billetterie
nom
du bar pour taiwan c'est bien conviviale
pas la route et aller simple pour taiwan
manu est ce que tu as une wild card
aussi un joueur je peux je cite en a pas
je peux descendre la liste
des teams et manifs et
non pas du web car park en effet et je
suis mort on rigole sur ta gueule j'ai
dirigé un de mes anciens joueurs tu veux
tellement un jour cru avec la maurienne
mais tant que j'ai suivi à chaque
fois qu'il nous écoute mais si votre
bien cher en tout cas voilà je suis
fière du chant pensionnaires du
championnat de taïwan 508
[Musique]
kings
c'est un il était en d2
et emmanuel cau l'éducateur
sont d'essence est grave
on arrive quand même rapidement à des
joueurs sont complètement complètement
disparu de la nba alors qu'on est que en
fait on fait ce podcast là maintenant
cette émission parce que c'est quatre
ans après donc c'est à dire que la
callas tic la qualifying offer sont
terminés donc soit ils ont re signé un
deuxième contrat nba soit ils ont dégagé
à peu près voir quelle équipe ont réussi
ou non le deuxième course
c'est une catastrophe
bien même court on n'attend pas beaucoup
de soutien
il n'y a quasiment que vous dira pas
quand je bois alex pas quand je vois
le seul joueur me semble qui a été
conservé le seul 30 qui a été conservé
par la franchise qui l'a drafté dans
deux joueurs est-ce que vous pouvez nous
les sites et déjà rapidement s'est dotée
bloc des landes brooks
donc même si ce rapt est déjà pas si mal
white et maurice est monté m'adresse
il ya globalement un potentiel hold'em
team là sur le chien le deuxième tour
qui est qu'il fabuleux ah oui oui non on
était sûr et même au premier tour donc
dès qu'on a passé bam adebayo en fait ça
devient terrible ben ahmed et bayeux 14
oui elle ensuite je suis une personne
n'existe plus en juillet il a fait un
thème des exils saison justin patten
n'existe plus des problèmes nous à elle
selon métro à la flore et le chip il
était pour les ouest phoenix en début
d'année il est probablement l'un des
10 qui est en toi houston l'an passé
dj wilson
qu'on salue ce tract se termine
aujourd'hui même à tort enfin en solo
gouttes
qui champions avec les boks bah oui
c'est grave pour halak a
d'ailleurs sterling brown cette année là
on avait fait un podcast sur quel est le
joint au deuxième temps qu'il envoie une
belle carrière nba j'avais choisi
stirling brown n empêche que tu étais
pas loin de la vérité parce que c'est un
des des plus belles carrières au second
tour même si là il n'est quand même pas
loin de sortir de la neuvième et il a il
a fait il a le souci je crois maintenant
[Musique]
mais donc je descends la listed gelis
je ne sais pas où ils jouent vraiment je
viens souvent japon du changement tant
attendu
en rien le
bon john collins bel exemple de réussite
j'ai le dif et en chine ah voilà dj
libre qui avait été drafté grâce à
langnau bonheur
c'est fait attention
aux coéquipiers dé des joueurs très trop
fort
john collins
joxe bah oui
et donc après entre 20 et 30 il y avait
donc des belles réussites j'arrête allen
ojjeh année nobi
kaiku jma d'eric white josh charles
john obi et et on l'avait tous dans le
top 10 jusqu'à demain qui se place ouais
ouais
bah d'ailleurs en fait il y avait une
stat incroyable
comme quoi parfois il faut faire
confiance
à indiana
son adversaire direct vue qui s'était
blessé il avait joué que dix ou douze
matches son adversaire direct n'avait
jamais scorer sur lui en dix ou douze
matches
0 % de réussite à wynau be quand tu vois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quand même
quasiment à 20 points de moyenne c'est
pas loin d'être un d'être un joli steen
par rapport à haut niveau et 41
c'est exemplaire pareil pour des ricoh a
été drafté par les spurs derek white
c'était la belle histoire de cette draft
là on se rappelle le mec qui avait
lui-même payé il me semble pour être
pris dans une équipe de d3 division iii
ancien il était arrivé finalement deux
ans après en division une il avait
explosé pendant sa saison junior a été
drafté par les spurs et maintenant il a
quatre ans 70 millions
vodeclic jouer live à san antonio quand
je suis à lévis est exaucé en 2019 il
est incroyable ne peuvent pas ne pas
l'avoir sur le terrain
de jeu
arrachant une transe match play off
contre denver que j'avais été voir il y
avait eu 36 subie à tous quelque chose
et
d'eric white donc fait partie des
réussites et j'ai un autre alors en fait
utah a fait deux très dans cette draft
là puisque donovan mitchell est drafté
par les nuggets qui ont eu beaucoup
donné puisqu'ils ont envoyé très très
lines et
tyler hayden qui aujourd'hui n'est plus
dans le je pense qu'être
en échange à au jazz
non ils ont pris ces deux joueurs là ils
ont envoyé donovan mitchell au jazz
bravo
denver nuggets
et
utah n'a pas tout fait bien à ce moment
là parce que zulte à trets et venir
tony bradley
avec le 28e soit c'est un peu leur
spécialité de faire venir des grands
oui
je me rappelle très bien ces syndromes
mark eaton ça ils ont toujours un intrus
qui leur est il leur faut il leur faut
également
et donc il y deux choix de deuxième tour
denis bradley et ses deux choix sont
devenus puisqu'il ya eu des prêts sont
devenus de jascha et thomasg aujourd'hui
deux joueurs de rotation n'diaye très
bonne facture'
le prin dans mon équipe n'importe quand
c'est ça ton masque bientôt
puis et donc du coup très fort et donc
après le début du second tour comme je
disais tout à l'heure
jackson mont daisen rythme on déjoue
belles choses en défense quand il veut
ouais si windu franck maison arabe jonah
pole dance et que des joueurs
en train d'enchaîner les taste contract
donc pour conclure une grappe 2010 est
franchement pas
de français sur un deuxième tour ouais
enfin le deuxième tour alpha qabatya une
fois qu'ils avaient en fin de deuxième
et mathias le sort mathieu je le sors un
peu plus au match acheté au sort de huit
mois et 1 50 c'est ça et aujourd'hui un
bien qui il appartient toujours aux
sites yahoo il appartient aux knicks
ouais et on pourrait donc un joueur que
j'aime bien également mais qui vont qui
traîne ses guêtres à l'olympiakos et
alexander dizaine comme une espèce de
deux postes cas de gauche et très
efficace en sortie de banc des joueurs
intéressants pour les uns une bulgare et
bulgares du gard
et après sur le deuxième quelques
joueurs traînent encore des réussites on
a dit dillon brooks est monté maurice
mais c'était un brown aussi
al zayat einstein de rien cherchez pas
damian dodson a bien réussi mais
maintenant ils viennent mais il à vous
apporter des flots de la new york qui
joue avec les knicks cette saison
la tchadienne allen l'a dit
bourg en bresse on y joue match
après c'était donc automates bryant et
puis le reste s'est sorti
tout ça pour dire que les joueurs du
second tour qu'on réussit manu benz on
peut leur en fait pour réussir au second
tour faut avoir ces bêtes à ce que je
vais dire un gros point fort qui va nous
permettre d'avoir du temps de jeu en nba
quoi monter maurice joue un rôle il
résonne une raison de une on nous donnez
moi une raison des bonnes raisons montée
maurice raciste assure
ratio assisté en over of de chart choix
à iowa state jeu si je me souviens bien
sterling bas on était déjà athlétique
shooter donc je prends
et 1 à 10 kg de dillon brooks était
moins évident comme ron bloom ouais j'y
croyais pas du tout dylan brooks puis
finalement jamais être complètement tort
mais solide blonde qui était fan factor
de shannon brown je peux aussi vous
rappelez lui avec
le couvent bleu contre fou de chagrin
ouais 2009 non ouais
enfin voilà les anecdotes familiales et
donc à yannick beaucoup
dénoncent et ses fameuses semelles il
est beau on m'a demandé tout bientôt
ouais
j'avais des problèmes de genou de
mémoire
justifie santé authier sud est du coup
il était descendu à indiana
entre-temps plus ben t'es trop loin du
oui la grèce en outre genou un max
dernier pile aura joué au basket depuis
c'est ça c'est ça bon en tout cas merci
beaucoup à toutes les personnes du chat
qui ont interagi avec nous pendant
pendant ce live c'était ses terres un
très bon live on s'est bien amusé on a
refait cette cuvée 2010 est qui
franchement bon
c'était pas un plaisir mais l'année
prochaine on va se faire plaisir parce
que eh ben c'est 2018 les
2018 ça veut dire notamment luca luca
luca
parmi le maglev comparis alexander
schall draft exceptionnel 2018 femmes
costaud sur le web quelle vedette
anglaise
mais on mais on s'y attendait
les niveaux l'aube brave généralement
d'éclat mais trop surpris à la fin
messieurs si vous avez un mot de la fin
c'est maintenant sinon je magnétoscope
ouais mais
c'est fini car